IN MY OPINION OTHER SPORTS DON'T
HOLD A CANDLE TO THE SCRUTINY
THAT IS APPLIED TO RACING IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND MOST OTHER RACING
JURISDICTIONS.
LAST NIGHT TWENTY FOUR MAJOR
LEAGUE TEAMS PLAY BASEBALL GAMES.
I STRONGLY DOUBT THAT THEY WIND
UP THE PLAYERS.
IN A LINE AFTER THE GAME.
AND SAID YOU YOU YOU AND YOU.
WE NEED TESTS.
HERE'S YOUR CUP.
WE DO THAT AFTER EVERY RACE
EVERY DAY.
OF COURSE OUR NEW SUBSTANCES
THAT MAY NOT YET BE DETECTABLE.
IT TOOK YEARS BEFORE BARRY BONDS
AND LANCE ARMED ARMSTRONG WERE
CAUGHT.
WERE CAUGHT.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT THE MEDI
LAB KEEPS OUR SAMPLES FOR TWO
YEARS FOR RETROACTIVE TESTING.
UNTIL NEW TESTS CAN BE DEVELOPED.
OTHER SPORTS ARE MANAGED BY
LEGAL OFFICES.
WE DON'T MANAGER RACING WE
REGULATED.
UNDER THE LAWS OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE C. H. R. B. RULES AND
REGULATIONS.
EVERY POSITIVE TEST IS
INVESTIGATED BY ONE OF OUR
INVESTIGATORS.
AND A COMPLAINT FILED AGAINST
THE LICENSEE.
THE BOARD TAKES EACH ONE VERY
SERIOUSLY.
BY WAY OF EXAMPLE A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO A COMPLAINT WAS FILED
AGAINST A TRAINER FOR HIS THIRD
CLENBUTEROL VIOLATION.
AFTER THE HEARING THE BOARD
SUSPENDED HIS TRAINER'S LICENSE
THROUGH ITS TERM.
AND FIND THAT TRAINOR A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
THOSE VIOLATIONS.
EVERYTHING WE DO IS IS ABOVE
BOARD AND OUT IN THE OPEN.
EVERY DISCIPLINARY RULING OR
LOSS OF A HORSE IS REPORTED IN
OUR WEEKLY STEWARDS MINUTES AND
AND OUR WEB PAGE.
IN THAT SPIRIT OF TRANSPARENCY
I'D LIKE TO UPDATE YOU ON THE
STATUS PHONE OF OUR
INVESTIGATIONS.
INTO THE FATALITIES AT SANTA
ANITA.
OUR THIRTEEN INVESTIGATORS ARE
SWORN PEACE OFFICERS.
WE HAVE FOUR OF THEM WORKING
FULL TIME.
ON THE TWENTY THREE NECROPSY
INVESTIGATIONS.
AS YOU PROBABLY HEARD IT'S A
JOINT INVESTIGATION WITH THE LOS
ANGELES DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE.
WE HAVE ISSUED SEVENTY SUBPOENAS
SO FAR.
IN INTERVIEWS OF VETERINARIANS
TRAINERS AND JOCKEYS ASSOCIATED
WITH EACH OF THE HORSES ARE
ONGOING.
SO FAR WE'VE COMPLETED FORTY SIX
OF THOSE INTERVIEWS.
WE HAVE TWENTY ONE INTERVIEWS
YET TO BE COMPLETED.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A VERY
THOROUGH AND CAREFUL PROCESS WE
ANTICIPATE THAT NEARLY ALL THESE
CASES WILL BE COMPLETED.
IN THE NEXT THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE
DAYS.
AND FINALLY A NOTE ABOUT SAFETY
WE ARE THE ONLY JURISDICTION IN
THE COUNTRY WAS SAFETY STEWARDS
ASSIGNED TO EACH RACE. TO
ENFORCE RULES AND PROCEDURES
DESIGNED TO ENSURE THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE RACE HORSES.
THESE SAFETY STORED SPEND
CONSIDERABLE TIME THE STABLE
AREAS AND ON THE RACETRACK.
MONITORING THE PROPER TREATMENT
OF HORSES.
MISTREATMENT OF FORCES IS NOT
TOLERATED.
THE C. H. R. B. HAS A SUPPOSED
HAS A SPECIFIC ANIMAL WELFARE
PROVISION IN ITS REGULATIONS TO
PROSECUTE CRUELTY.
MISTREATMENT NEGLECT OR ABUSE.
AND WHEN APPROPRIATE CASES CAN
BE AND ARE REFERRED TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
I AM PLEASED TO REPORT TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
THAT THE WORST RACING BOARD
CHAIRMAN WINNER AND MYSELF.
HAVE HAD VERY PRODUCTIVE
POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS.
WITH KATHY GILL YERMO FROM PETER.
AND JUDY MEN -- SO FROM SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION.
WE TOGETHER HAVE IDENTIFIED A
NUMBER OF INITIATIVES THAT WE
BELIEVE CAN BE ACHIEVED.
AND WE DO THANK.
THAT IF WE'RE INVITED BACK.
IN A SUBSEQUENT YEAR.
BEFORE TOO LONG WE WILL BE ABLE
TO SAY THE CALIFORNIA RACING IS
NOT ONLY THE SAFEST IN AMERICA.
BUT AMONG THE SAFEST ANYWHERE.
THERE ARE MANY MORE OF THOSE
INITIATIVES ON THE BOOKS ARE IN
THE REGULATORY PIPELINE.
AND I'D LIKE TO TURN OVER THE
DISCUSSION TO OUR VICE CHAIR.
COMMISSIONER MADELINE AUERBACH
FOR MORE ON THOSE MEASURES.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN DODD AND GERMAN GRAY.
ON MEMBERS OF THIS JOINT
COMMITTEE I WANT TO ASSURE YOU
THAT THE BOARD IS DOING
EVERYTHING IN ITS POWER TO
ENHANCE THE SAFETY AND WELFARE
OF OUR HORSES.
BEGINNING WITH ITS MEETING IN
MARCH THE BOARD HAS NUMBER ONE
PRE AUTHORIZED THE RELOCATION OF
THE RACE MEET FROM SENATE NEEDED
TO LOS ALAMEDA IS.
SUBJECT TO APPROVAL BY BOTH OF
THOSE PARTIES SHOULD THAT MOVED
BECOME NECESSARY. TO WE HAVE
SUSPENDED AUTHORIZED THRESHOLDS
FOR ELEVEN ANTI INFLAMMATORY
MEDICATIONS.
AT ALL RACETRACKS IN CALIFORNIA
THIS MEANS THAT THERE IS A ZERO
TOLERANCE. FOR THE PRESENCE OF
THESE MEDICATIONS AND POST RACE
TESTS.
EVEN THOUGH THESE ARE
THERAPEUTIC DRUGS THEIR PRESENCE
CAN HIDE OR MASK AND SOUNDNESS.
EVERY RESOURCES EXAMINED BY THE
STATE VETERINARIAN ON RACE DAY
WHO WILL NOW BE BETTER ABLE
RECORD.
BE BETTER ABLE TO RECOGNIZE THE
PROBLEM SHOULD ONE EXIST.
INTRODUCED REGULATORY LANGUAGE.
TO STRICTLY LIMIT THE USE OF THE
RIDING CROP THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE WILL ALLOW THE WRITERS
TO CARRY THE CROP FOR SAFETY
PURPOSES ONLY.
IT IS BEING PREPARED FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD.
NUMBER FOUR WE'VE INCREASED THE
OFFICIAL VETERINARIAN SAFETY
STORED AND INVESTIGATORS STAFF.
AT SANTA ANITA NUMBER.
FIVE WE'VE GREATLY EXPANDED OUT
OF COMPETITION TESTING WITH
STIFF PENALTIES ALTHOUGH WE
RARELY FIND PROHIBITED
SUBSTANCES IN THESE TESTS.
THIS REGULATION PUTS TEETH IN
THIS PROGRAM.
IN RACING IF THE MEDICATION IS
NOT ONE OF THE FEW THAT IT IS
EXPLICITLY PERMITTED THAN IT IS
PROHIBITED.
NUMBER SIX MARK REGULATORY
LANGUAGE TO MAKE ME CROP TEE
REDUCE MANDATORY.
ALL FUTURE REVIEWS GOING FORWARD
WILL INCLUDE OF C. HRB
INVESTIGATOR THE OFFICIAL
VETERINARIAN AND A KNEE CROPSEY
STEWARD.
REQUIRE TRAINERS TO MAINTAIN
COMPLETE RECORDS OF ALL THAT
NERI TREATMENTS AND MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE UPON DEMANDED THE
EXAMINING VETERINARIAN IN A REAL
TIME MANNER ON RACE DAY.
OR ANY OTHER TIME AS REQUIRED.
ELIMINATE THE USE OF THIS
FASCINATES IN RACE HORSES
ESTABLISH THRESHOLD LIMITS FOR
CERTAIN PERMITTED MEDICATIONS
DURING WORKOUTS.
AND SEVEN AND OUR BOARD MEETING
TOMORROW WILL DISCUSS CHANGES TO
SEE HRB RULES.
WITH RESPECT TO LIMITATIONS OF
FOR DRUGS MIGHT LASIX.
USE BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY
UNDER CONSIDERATION WILL BE THE
ELIMINATION OF LASIX FOR ALL TWO
YEAR OLDS.
AS WELL AS ALL HORSES RACING
GRADED STAKES EVENTS.
AS A RESULT OF THE ZERO
TOLERANCE MEDICATION POLICY
MENTIONED ABOVE.
AND THE OTHERS TO COME
CALIFORNIA IS NOW THE STRICTEST
RACING JURISDICTION IN AMERICA.
OUR GOAL IS TO LOOK BACK AND
REALIZE THAT THIS WAS JUST THE
START OF OUR COOPERATIVE EFFORT.
TO MAKE RACING AS SAFE AS IT CAN
BE FOR BOTH THE HORSE.
AND THE RIDER.
FINALLY I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF YOUR LEADERSHIP.
IN MOVING SB FOUR SIX NINE YOUR
INTEREST IN THE INDUSTRY AND
DESIRE TO STRENGTHEN THE
AUTHORITY OF THE BOARD. TO ACT
QUICKLY TO PROTECT THE SAFETY OF
BOTH HORSE AND RIDER IS VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED AND IT'S
NECESSARY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
DOC.
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME
START TO REGARD DURING THE COIN
MEDICAL DIRECTOR AT UC DAVIS
SCHOOL OF VETERINARY MEDICINE
I'M ASSIGNED FULL TIME TO THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD
THROUGH AN INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENT.
MY ROLE IS TO LIAISON BETWEEN
THE BOARD AND UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF
VETERINARY MEDICINE ADVISE THE
BOARD ON MATTERS RELATING TO
MEDICATION AND DRUG TESTING TO
PRACTICE OF VETERINARY MEDICINE
AND THE HEALTH AND SAFETY.
OF COURSES.
BESIDES THE COIN MEDICAL
DIRECTORS CONTRACT THE SCHOOL
CONTRACTS WITH THE BOARD FOR
DRUG TESTING DR HEATHER CAN
NATURE VETERINARY PHARMACOLOGIST
WHO WILL.
DISCUSS THE EQUINE -- MANDY
EQUINE ANALYTICAL LABORATORIES
DRUG TESTING PROGRAM IS HERE
TODAY AND STILL COVER THAT THE
THIRD CONTRACTORS BETWEEN THE
SCHOOL IN THE C. H. R. P. FOR
THE NECROPSY PROGRAM.
AND THIS WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN NINETY AND IS
CONSIDERED AN INTERNATIONAL
MODEL.
SHORTLY AFTER THE KNEE CRAPPIE
PROGRAM BEGAN IT BECAME CLEAR
THAT WE NEEDED DATA BETTER
DIAGNOSTIC IMAGING THE NONPROFIT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EQUINE
FOUNDATION -- IT IS BUILT A
NUCLEAR IMAGING FACILITY AT
SANTA ANITA AND SENT STAND
TWELVE THOUSAND OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED NUCLEAR
SUMMIT GRAPHIC EXAMINATION.
BEEN PERFORMED. TO IDENTIFY
INJURIES TO THE HUMERUS SCAPULA
PELVIS LUMBAR IN OTHER AREAS
THAT ARE NOT AMENABLE TO REGULAR
RADIOGRAPHIC EXAMINATION.
WE ARE NOW IN THE PROCESS FROM
THAT SAME THE PROPERTY PROGRAM.
AND FROM RESEARCH FROM MY
COLLEAGUES THE UC DAVIS -- TO TO
DEVELOP A STANDING POSITRON
EMISSION TOMOGRAPHY OR PET SCAN
THAT'S A THREE D. NUCLEAR
IMAGING MODALITY.
THAT WE THINK WILL ALLOW US TO
IDENTIFY PRE EXISTING LESIONS IN
THE FAT LOCKED PADLOCK BEING THE
MOST COMMON CAUSE OF BREAKDOWNS
AND TO SET OR NOT.
CURRENTLY AMENABLE -- TO
DIAGNOSTIC IMAGING.
THE PAD IS BEING ACQUIRED
THROUGH A MAJOR DONATIONS FROM
THE STRONG GROUP IN A CLINICAL
VALIDATION.
AT SANTA NEED IS BEING FUNDED
FROM THROUGH A GRANT FROM THE
GRAYSON JOCKEY CLUB RESET SEARCH
FOUNDATION TO UC DAVIS.
IN SPITE OF THE PROBLEMS WE'VE
HAD THIS WINTER IT.
TO SANITY THAT THE SCHOOL YEAR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WILL BE THE
SECOND LOWEST NUMBER PATHOLOGIES
CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS.
WE'VE REDUCE FATALITIES BY OVER
50% SINCE THE LAST TEN TO TWELVE
YEARS OR SAFETY HAS BEEN A
CONSTANT CONCERN OF THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD IS
ANY REVIEW WITH THE MEDICATION
SAFETY AND WELFARE COMMITTEE AND
THE BOARD -- WILL SHOW.
THE SAME CAN BE SAID FOR
NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
THE JOCKEY CLUB WELFARE AND
SAFETY SUMMIT TO THOROUGHBRED
SAFETY COMMITTEE IN THE NTR A
ACCREDITATION PROGRAM.
I HAVE A WHOLE LIST OF DIFFERENT
TASKS THAT WE'VE DONE SOME OF
THEM ARE REDUNDANT FROM THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER SO -- WE DO
HAVE A A PREPARED MATERIAL THAT
I'LL GIVE TO YOU LATER -- BUT
YOU KNOW IT'S THE REALITY OF IT
IS THAT NOBODY WANTS REGULATION
UNTIL THERE'S A QUE QUE
CATASTROPHE.
IN EVERY NEW REGULATION HAS BEEN
A BATTLE AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
A BATTLE AND SOMETIMES -- ALE
DOESN'T HELP.
BUT REGARDLESS I DON'T THINK
ANYONE IN THE C. H. R. B. --
THINKS THAT THERE ISN'T MORE
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
I KNOW WHY DON'T AND I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT WAYS TO MAKE RACING
SAFER AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
DR.
HI DR HEATHER CONNECTION
PROFESSOR BASED OUT OF THE KALE
MADDIE EQUINE IN LITTLE
CHEMISTRY LAB.
SO DOCTOR THIRTY TALKED ABOUT
THE SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE TO
THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD SO I'M JUST GONNA TAKE A
FEW MINUTES TO SUMMARIZE THE LAB
ITSELF AND THE DRUG TESTING
PROGRAM.
SO THE MEDI LAB IS ONE OF THE
TOP IF NOT THE TOP DRUG TESTING
PROGRAMS IN THE COUNTRY.
IT IS UNIQUE AMONGST OTHER DRUG
TESTING LABS IN THAT IT'S
COMPRISED OF BOTH A VERY ROBUST
DRUG TESTING COMPONENT.
AS WELL AS A VERY STRONG
RESEARCH ARM.
SO TO SPEAK TO THE DRUG TESTING
ON THE LAB UTILIZES MASS
SPECTROMETRY WHICH IS ONE OF THE
MOST SENSITIVE MOST ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGIES OUT THERE.
IS CONSIDERED THE GOLD STANDARD
FOR DRUG TESTING.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE METHODOLOGY IN
PLACE THAT ALLOWS US TO SCREEN
FOR NEARLY A THOUSAND DIFFERENT
COMPOUNDS AND WE ADD TO THAT AS
AS NECESSARY. TO LOOK FOR THESE
COMPOUNDS IN BOTH BLOOD AND
URINE SAMPLES.
OUR LAB OPERATES UNDER AYSO
SEVENTEEN ZERO TWO FIVE
ACCREDITATION REQUIREMENTS WERE
CREDITED BY A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
LABORATORY ACCREDITATION.
WE WERE ONE OF THE FIRST LAPS TO
BE ACCREDITED BY THE RACING
MEDICATION AND TESTING
CONSORTIUM.
AND WE'RE THE ONLY A UNITED
STATES LAB TO BE CERTIFIED BY
THE INTERNATIONAL FEDERATION OF
HORSERACING AUTHORITIES.
AS FOR THE RESEARCH COMPONENT
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT MAKES THIS LAB UNIQUE.
IS THAT WE'RE ABLE TO RESPOND
VERY QUICKLY TO WHAT WE REFER TO
AS EMERGING THREATS SO MERGING
THREATS MIGHT BE COMPOUNDS WHERE
THERE'S RUMORED RUMORS OF ITS
USE.
OR SOMETHING THAT WE FIND ON A
ROUTINE SCREEN THAT WE HAVEN'T
PREVIOUSLY IDENTIFIED.
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THE
MAHDI LAB AND ONE THING THAT
HELPS US REACT QUICKLY TO THESE
EMERGING THREATS.
IS OUR EXERCISE THOROUGHBRED
RESEARCH HEARD THAT WE MAINTAIN
THIS IS A HEARD THAT IS
MAINTAINED BY THE LAB SO WE HAVE
READY ACCESS TO THESE ANIMALS.
THEY'RE ALL YOUNG EXERCISED
THOROUGHBRED HORSES SO BY
EXERCISED WE TRY TO KEEP THEM
FIT USING A COMBINATION --
EXERCISE REGIMEN INCLUDING HIGH
SPEED TREADMILL.
SO THIS IS OUR ATTEMPT TO AS
BEST WE CAN IN A CONTROLLED
RESEARCH CITING.
KIND OF MIMIC AT YOUR TYPICAL
RESOURCE.
SO HAVING ACCESS TO THESE
ANIMALS AT ANY TIME ALLOWS US
RESPOND LET US RESPOND VERY
QUICKLY TO EMERGING THREATS WE
CAN VERY QUICKLY ASSESS HOW
COMPOUNDS MOVE THROUGHOUT THE
ANIMAL SYSTEM WHERE THEY GO HOW
THEIR LIMITED.
THE PHARMACOLOGIC OR PHYSIOLOGIC
EFFECTS OF THESE DIFFERENT
COMPOUNDS AND PROBABLY MOST
IMPORTANTLY FROM A REGULATORY
SPECTRUM PERSPECTIVE WE CAN
DEVELOP AND VALIDATE SENSITIVE
ANALYTICAL METHODS THAT CAN THEN
BE USED AS PART OF THE
REGULATORY SCREEN SO WE
REGULARLY TRANSFER THESE METHODS
FROM THE RESEARCH ARM. TO THE
DRUG TESTING PORTION OF THE
PROGRAM.
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN VERY PROLIFIC
WE'VE PUBLISHED UPWARDS OF
NINETY MANUSCRIPTS IN PEER
REVIEW JOURNALS RELATED TO
EQUINE PHARMACOLOGY.
THIS INFORMATION IS THEN USED BY
OTHER DRUG TESTING LABS BOTH
FROM A MYTHOLOGICAL STANDPOINT
AS WELL AS FROM.
A REGULATORY STANDPOINT IN TERMS
OF ESTABLISHING.
REGULATORY RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE LOCATION OF THE MADDIE LAB
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
MORE SPECIFICALLY AT THE SCHOOL%
OF VETERINARY MEDICINE ALSO
PROVIDES A NUMBER OF BENEFITS TO
OUR LAB.
SO BEING PART OF THE VETERINARY
SCHOOL ALLOWS US READY ACCESS TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH WITH EXPERTISE
IN MANY DIFFERENT AREAS.
NOT ONLY DOES THIS INCLUDE
PHARMACOLOGY IN ANALYTICAL
CHEMISTRY BUT ORTHOPEDICS EQUINE
GENETICS DIAGNOSTIC IMAGING AND
EACH EQUINE EXERCISE PHYSIOLOGY.
SO WE FORMED MANY COLLABORATIONS
WITH THESE DIFFERENT INDIVIDUALS
ARE EXPERTS IN THESE FIELDS.
AND THIS ALLOWS US -- TO PUSH
FORWARD WITH OUR RESEARCH AND
REALLY ADVANCE OUR RESEARCH
DEVELOP NEW ANALYTICAL
TECHNIQUES. ONE EXAMPLE OF THIS
IS THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
COLLABORATING WITH AN EXPERT IN
EQUINE GENETICS TO DEVELOP A NEW
METHODOLOGY.
THAT WE HOPE TO YOU USE IN THE
FUTURE TO AUGMENT OUR CURRENT
METHODS FOR THE DETECTION OF THE
BLOOD DOPING AGENT OR A THREE
POINT IN.
SO IT IS OUR HOPE THAT THIS NEW
METHODOLOGY WILL ENHANCE OUR
ABILITY TO DETECT ADMINISTRATION
OF MICRO DOSES OF IVO THROUGH
THE USE OF BIOMARKERS OF
ADMINISTRATION SO ALTERNATIVE
TECHNIQUES TO DETECTING DRUG
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL ADVANTAGE
TO BEING PART OF THE UNIVERSITY
AND THE SCHOOL OF THAT MAN AS WE
ARE ABLE TO USE THE UNIVERSITY'S
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ADVANCE OUR
RESEARCH GOALS.
SO WE USE THE UNIVERSITY'S
INSTITUTIONAL ANIMAL CARE AND
USE COMMITTEE THEY REGULARLY
REVIEW ALL OF OUR ANIMAL STUDIES
ALL OF OUR PROTOCOLS.
THE VETERINARY FACILITIES TO
HOUSE OUR HORSES THE TREADMILL
THAT'S LOCATED AT THE VET SCHOOL
AND THEN ALSO FACILITIES TO
CONDUCT RESEARCH STUDIES.
AND THEN LASTLY AS WELL AS BEING
PART OF THE VET SCHOOL THE
MOUNTIE LAB IS LOCATED WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL HEALTH AND
FOOD SAFETY LAB AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS.
WHICH IS AN A. A. B. L. D.
ACCREDITED LAB GIVING ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS SUCH AS A BUILT IN
SAFETY PROGRAM.
BOARD CERTIFIED PATHOLOGISTS
THAT SUPPORT THE KNEE CROPSEY
PROGRAM AND OTHER SERVICES SUCH
AS TOXICOLOGY.
THE TOXICOLOGY GROUP IS ALSO I
SO SEVENTEEN ZERO TWO FIVE
ACCREDITED FOR COBALT TESTING IN
SUPPORT OF THE CEDAR BE DRUG
TESTING PROGRAM.
AND SO THAT'S ALL I HAVE FOR
THIS AFTERNOON SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL TAKE SOME --
QUESTIONS AT THIS POINT IN TIME
[inaudible]
YES.
YES THANK YOU OF THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU FOR APPEARING TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING HERE AND IT
WAS VITALLY IMPORTANT TO ALL OF
US TO FIND OUT EXACTLY WHAT'S
TAKING PLACE -- IF YOU CAN JUST
KIND OF WALK US THROUGH --
DIRECTOR I UNDERSTAND WHO ARE
TWENTY THREE HORSES AT WHAT
POINT DID YOU GET.
VETERINARIANS AND EVERYONE
INVOLVED AT THE THE SIX PARTS
SEVEN HORSE AND OURS WHEN DID IT
IT BECOME AN URGENT URGENT
MATTER WHERE THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY HAD TO BE A CALLED AND
WHICH ARE AN AUTOPSY DONE.
WALK US THROUGH THIS WHOLE --
TRAUMA THAT YOU ALL WENT THROUGH.
WE TRACK EVERY FATALITY AS IT
OCCURS AND OF COURSE WHEN YOU
STUDY.
ANY KIND OF STATISTICAL OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME.
YOU ALLOW FOR THE POSSIBILITY OF
AN ANOMALY.
AND THE EARLY PART OF THE SENATE
NEED A MEETING.
WITH A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RAIN.
ACTUALLY THE NUMBERS FROM THE
VERY FIRST PART WERE NOT MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN PREVIOUS YEARS.
BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN THOSE
NUMBERS BECAME MORE NUMEROUS --
WE IMMEDIATELY GOT DR ARTHUR
INVOLVED -- SPOKE NOT ONLY WITH
OUR OFFICIAL VETERINARIAN BUT
THE TRACK VETERINARIAN ALSO THE
RACING OFFICE AT SANTA ANITA.
MANAGEMENT IS SANTA.
AND THESE NUMBERS BEGAN TO
ESCALATE RATHER RAPIDLY.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE FRUSTRATION.
ON THE PART OF THE BOARD.
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO STEP IN AND
STOP THINGS.
AS A RESULT SENATOR DODD OF
SOMEBODY GERMAN GRAY.
HAVE MOVED THIS BILL AS BEFORE
SIXTY NINE WHICH WILL GIVE THE
BOARD THE AUTHORITY.
IN FUTURE TO STEP IN AND ACT
IMMEDIATELY.
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO DO THAT SO
I THINK THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION SIR IS THAT -- WE WERE
AWARE OF THE PROBLEM FROM THE
START.
YET.
I THINK THOSE PROBABLY IS FAIR
TO SAY THAT WE EXPECTED THAT IT
WAS AN ANOMALY AND THAT IS
ENOUGH AS A MATTER OF FACT
THINGS WOULD CALM DOWN.
IN RETURN TO NORMAL.
INSTEAD THEY RAMPED UP
DRAMATICALLY IN A SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME -- SO WE DID ACT WE
TALKED MANAGEMENT AT SANTA ANITA.
THEY DECIDED TO CLOSE TRAINING
FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS -- RE OPEN.
AT ANOTHER FATALITY AND THEN
THEY DECIDED TO SHUT DOWN
ALTOGETHER.
I THINK YOU PROBABLY KNOW THE
REST OF THE TIME LINE.
SO WE WERE INVOLVED EVERY STEP
OF THE WAY.
AND DID YOU FIND THAT THOSE LAST
TWO HORSES DIED I THINK THIS
LAST WEEKEND.
PERHAPS THIS SAME TYPE OF EITHER
MEDICATION OR OR SOIL OR I MEAN
HAVE YOU GOTTEN A CLUE WHAT THIS
MIGHT BE SO WHAT I'LL GIVE THIS
TO DOCTOR ARE THERE IN A MINUTE
BUT THE ONE THING THAT STE
MEDICALLY DIFFERENT ABOUT THE
PREVIOUS ONES AND THESE.
IS.
MAYBE NOT AND MAYBE IT'S NOT
ENTIRELY THERE BECAUSE WE DID
OUR BRAIN RECENTLY BUT I THINK
DOCTOR ARE THERE CAN COMMENT ON
THIS BETTER THAN I CAN BUT THE
EARLY ONES.
CERTAINLY WERE AFFECTED BY THE
FOURTEEN INCHES OF RAIN DURING
THE SAME.
PERIOD THE PREVIOUS YEAR THAT
GOT.
TO SELL WAS CREATED A RATHER
UNIQUE SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES IN
TERMS OF MAINTAINING THE
RACETRACK SEALING IT OPENING IT
BACK UP SEALING THE CEILING
AGAIN -- AND I THINK THERE'S NO
QUESTION IT PUT VULNERABLE
HORSES MORE AT RISK.
THE FOCUS OF MANY OF THE THINGS
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR TODAY IS
ABOUT BETTER IDENTIFYING THOSE
VULNERABLE HORSES.
AT THE BOARD ALSO WILL BE
CONSIDERING SOME RESTRICTIONS ON
TRACK MAINTENANCE GOING FORWARD
DOCTOR ARE THROUGH YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT THE MEDICAL PART OF AND
BEFORE YOU GO ON DR I I I ASK.
FOR IN A RESULT OF AN AUTOPSY
DID YOU CONDUCT ANY IS ALONG THE
WAY.
EVERY WORDS DIES WITHIN THE
ENCLOSURE OF A BE RAISING YOUR
CALIFORNIA.
THE LABORATORY SITE SO THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER IN THE YOU
KNOW WE DO THAT WITH YOU.
EXACTLY SURE WE EVEN HAVE A A
VERY ONLY IF THAT WAS ENFORCED --
THE PROPERTY SO WE ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THESE WE MONITOR I'M I WANT.
EVERYONE. TO COME THROUGH SO
THAT THAT IS STANDARD OPERATING
PROCEDURE FOR US.
BUT GET YOUR SECOND QUESTION THE
THE LATEST TO THE TALON THESE
ARE DIFFERENT THAN THE FIRST --
TWENTY THREE ONE OF THOSE WAS
SENT DOWN WHICH IS ABOUT 5% OF
THE TRAINING AND RACING BUT ALEX
OVER ALL.
THE TWENTY TWO MUSCLES SO ALLEN
THESE NINETEEN OF THOSE TWENTY
TWO MORE OF THE FACT LOCKED.
WOULD BE INCLUDING THE PROXIMAL
SESAMOID BONE WHICH IS A BONUS
VERY PRONE. TO EIGHT HIGH
INTENSITY EXERCISE -- A
COMBINATION OF EIGHT EIGHT
FRANKLY HARD TRACKS IN
OVERTRAINING.
AND WE'RE STILL IN A
INVESTIGATION PART OF THAT AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
FIND BUT EIGHT THAT'S A
PULMONARY STATEMENT -- SO I TAKE
THAT WITH A GRAIN OF SALT BUT
YEAH YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE THE LAST TWO ARE
DIFFERENT THAN THE FIRST.
TWENTY TWO MY FELLOW THE LAST
COUPLE QUESTIONS WE SHARE THE
COMMON DENOMINATOR BETWEEN THOSE
TWENTY THREE WERE ABLE TO
DISCOVER THAT.
IN THAT WHAT LED YOU TO TO GET
THE THE TO THE DA'S OFFICE
INVOLVED DID YOU SUSPECT
SOMETHING.
I WASN'T INVOLVED IN GETTING IT
DA'S OFFICE INVOLVED I LOOK AT
THIS MORE AS AN ACADEMIC -- IT --
EFFORT TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHY
THESE SOURCES FRACTURED AND HOW
WE CAN AVOID IT I MEAN THEY THEY
INVESTIGATIONS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE USUALLY
DO -- BUT YEAH THEY THE
COMMONALITY IS AT THE HORSES
HAVE ACCUMULATED MORE HIGH SPEED
EXERCISE IN A SHORTER PERIOD OF
TIME.
THE NICKEL HEARTS.
THEN I CAN ADDRESS THAT INVEST
THE DA'S PART OF THIS THING.
WE DID NOT APPROACH THE DA --
OTHERS DID ASK THE DA TO GET
INVOLVED.
AND SO THE THE DAY DECIDED -- TO
APPROACH US IN TO CONDUCT A
JOINT -- CAN INVESTIGATION ON ON
EACH OF THESE BAY TELL THESE THE
SANITY TO RETRACT HAS SUCH A
GREAT REPUTATION -- GOOD NUMBER
OF YEARS JUST A JUST A BEAUTIFUL
PLACE -- AND I'M SURE EVERYONE
THERE IS IS COOPERATING AND TRY
AND DO WHAT THEY CAN.
OF WHAT DO YOU THINK YOUR NEXT
STEP IS GOING TO BE HERE THE
NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS.
WELL WE'VE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED A
NUMBER OF PROVISIONS WE HAVE AND
MANAGEMENT AT SANTA ANITA HAS
YOU'LL HEAR FROM THEM A LITTLE
LATER -- IN THIS HEARING -- SO
WE'RE CONTINUING TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT -- WE CAN
POSSIBLY DO -- WE WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED A PROGRAM AT SANTA
AT DEL MAR THREE SUMMERS AGO.
AFTER THERE WAS A SPATTER OF
FATALITIES NOT NEARLY AS BAD AS
THIS BUT VERY ALARMING.
AND WORKING WITH DOCTOR ARTHUR
DOCTOR ARE THERE WITH THE OTHER
OFFICIAL THAT'S PUT TOGETHER A
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWED US TO
IDENTIFY HORSES THAT WORK RISK.
IT IS DOCTOR ARTHUR REFLECTED IN
HIS COMMENTS WE'RE VERY
ENCOURAGED WITH SEEN JUST SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN WE HAD
SEEN A 60% REDUCTION IN
FATALITIES.
SO THIS.
EXPERIENCE AT SANTA ANITA.
THIS YEAR -- STOPPED ALL OF THAT
PROGRESS IN ITS TRACKS.
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO TALK
ABOUT THOSE ACHIEVEMENTS IN
LIGHT OF WHAT'S HAPPENED -- BUT
I'M CONFIDENT THAT NOT ONLY ALL
OF THOSE CHANGES AND PROGRAMS
THAT WERE PUT INTO PLACE AS A
RESULT OF WHAT HAPPENED A DOWN
MARKET.
BUT MANY MORE JUST LIKE IT NOW
WHETHER ON THE PART OF THE BOARD
FOR THE PART OF MANAGEMENT AT
SANTA ANITA.
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO CHANGE
HAVE THEIR AFFECT ON RACING
GOING FORWARD.
IT IT SOUNDS WEIRD TO SAY BUT I
THINK THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
WITH ALL OF THE SAFETY MEASURES
NOW IN PLACE.
RACING IS NEVER BEEN SAFER IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IT IS.
ODDLY PROBABLY PARTLY BECAUSE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENED.
THANK YOU MISTER DIRECTOR --
THANK YOU CHAIR.
CENTER CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU.
FORGET MY VOICE A LITTLE RASPY
TODAY -- YES TIME MASS SENATOR
RUBIO I REPRESENT ACTUALLY SANTA
NEEDED TO MY DISTRICT AND TELL.
WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE -- I KNOW THAT THIS
IS A VERY SERIOUS ISSUE
ESPECIALLY FOR ALL OF US TOUGH
FOR ME PERSONALLY THE SAFETY OF
THE HORSES AND THE JOCKEY IS OF
UTMOST IMPORTANCE SPOT.
I REALLY WANT TO COMMEND YOU
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT -- YOU KNOW
YOU STEPPED UP AND I DID HEAR
ALL THE CHANGES THAT YOU'RE
IMPLEMENTING CURRENTLY.
AND I'VE ALSO MET UP WITH -- THE
SONICS GROUP AND THEY ALSO
SHARED SOME OF THE CHANGES THAT
THE CONTENT. TO IMPLEMENTED I
KNOW THAT THIS IS DIFFICULT
BECAUSE IT'S EMOTIONAL FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
MORE SUSTAIN.
BUT I THINK THAT WORK ON THE
RIGHT TRACK IN TERMS OF NOT
BEING TO NARAL ON ONE TRACK
VERSUS TRYING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM FOR CALIFORNIA.
I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS -- YOU MENTION AND I
THINK IT WAS YOU DOCTOR ARE
PRODUCT THERE YOU STATE YOUR
DEVELOPING A SCANNED A PET SCANS
SO WE DON'T HAVE. ONE CURRENTLY
THAT WORKS OUT RIGHT AT THAT HAS
BEEN USED.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW IF THIS IS
THE FIRST ONE THAT'S BEING --
DOCTOR NANCY SPRAY AT THE
BATTERY RADIOLOGIST AT THE THE
SCHOOL HERE IN DAVIS DEVELOPED
THE TECHNOLOGY -- FOR POSSIBLY
EMISSION TOMOGRAPHY IT'S THE
FIRST ONE TIME IT'S BEEN USEDIN
A HORSE.
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING IS STANDING THEY THEY
HAVE TO BE ANESTHETIZED FOR THE
WITH THE WORK THAT HE DID ON
CAMPUS.
BUT WHAT WHAT WHAT -- HE'S DOING
IN COOPERATION WITH A COMMERCIAL
COMPANY IS DEVELOPING A STANDING --
P. ET SCAN WHICH ALLOWS THE
HORSES NOT TO BE ANESTHETIZED
AND BE EXAMINED AT SANTA ANITA
OR FORTUNATE SANITY DO WE
ALREADY HAVE A NUCLEAR IMAGING
FACILITIES SO WE HAVE ALL THE
NUCLEAR MEDICINE LICENSES.
AND WE JUST MET EARLIER THIS
WEEK WITH THE MANUFACTURE AND
DOCTOR SPRY AT AND AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL HAVE IT THERE BEFORE --
BREEDERS CUP.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M IN THIS
QUESTION IS.
FOR I'M SORRY I DIDN'T GET YOUR
NAME EARLIER TODAY FOR GETTING
ME ONE SECOND HERE I THINK IT'S
TIME DR HEATHER.
WHAT I THINK IT WAS YOU I'M
SORRY FIGHT I WANT TO AYE SOME
TOO MANY WERE TALKING ONE OF YOU
WERE YOU WERE EXPRESSING OF
FINING YOU MET THE METHODOLOGIES
TO DETECT DRUG ADMINISTRATION?
CAN YOU TELL ME HOW LONG THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE AND WHEN YOU SEE
THIS BEING USED.
THE ONE AT THE EXAMPLE I GAVE
WAS THAT OF THE BLOOD THAT WE
NEED.
TO WAIT WHICH WE CURRENTLY DO
HAVE METHODOLOGY PLACE TO DETECT --
USING OUR CURRENT TECHNOLOGY BUT
WE'VE HEARD RUMORS OF MICRO.
WE'VE HEARD RUMORS OF MICRO
DISTINGUISHES ADMINISTRATION OF
LOW DOSES WITH -- HOPING TO GET
THE SAME EFFECT BUT YET
CIRCUMVENTING DETECTION
PROCEDURES SO WHAT WE ARE DOING
THERE IS TRYING TO DEVELOP
ESSENTIALLY BIOMARKERS.
SO THINGS THAT CHANGE IN
RESPONSE TO DRUG ADMINISTRATION
SO THAT WOULD HELP COMPLEMENT
OUR CURRENT TECHNOLOGY SO WE
COULD POTENTIALLY DEVELOP THIS
FOR OTHER DRUGS AS WELL.
THANK YOU WELL ONE OF THE
COMMENTS THAT I THAT I WANT
EXPRESSED OUT NOT ONLY BECAUSE
YOU KNOW AS I STATED BEFORE IT
IS IN MY DISTRICT AND I KNOW
THAT SENATE EMPLOYS SO MANY
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY AND
THEY'RE CONCERNED THEY'RE
WORRIED AND BEFORE. FOR ME
PERSONALLY I WANT TO MOVE VERY
CAREFULLY TO ENSURE THAT WE FIND
OUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO MAKE
THIS BETTER SO IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN AND THEN WE HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE HORSE.
RACING -- INDUSTRY THAT IS ALSO
THAT THE INTEGRITY IS STILL
INTACT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW KERRY
THERE'S A LOT OF THIS --
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DOG BEING
AND AND AND USING DRUGS ON
HORSES SO.
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TRYING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM
BUT I ALSO WANT TO CAUTION LIKE
I SAID ON MY COLLEAGUES TO MOVE
VERY CAUTIOUSLY BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW AS WE SPEAK WE HAVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE LISTENING.
THAT WORKS THERE AND AGAIN I
WANT TO BE VERY MINDFUL THAT
THIS IS THEIR LIVELIHOOD AND SO
I WANT TO MOVE WITH WITH DATA
WITH EVIDENCE AND WITH
INFORMATION ON OUR HANDS BUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TRYING TO
SELL THIS WITH US.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT
[inaudible]
BILLS.
OKAY -- I'VE I'VE I I'VE GOT A
QUESTION AB ANYBODY CAN TAKE
THIS.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN -- AT WHAT A
CATASTROPHIC INJURY IS AND WHY
DOES IT ALMOST ALWAYS LEAD TO
EUTHANASIA -- THE HORSE AND THEN
MAYBE THE LAST THING IS.
DO WE ALWAYS HAVE -- TO UTILIZE
THEM IS THERE SOME OTHER.
USE -- FOR THEM AB ONE THIS
WORLD.
YEAH I'LL TAKE THAT -- I'VE BEEN
I STARTED PRACTICING A PRACTICE
FOR THIRTY YEARS AND SANTA NEED
IN PRACTICE OF MY FORTY SECOND
OPENING -- DAY IT SANTA NEEDED
THIS YEAR.
AND THEIR HORSES STACKED -- WE
WOULD USE A NICE BACK FORTY TWO
YEARS AGO THAT ARE REPAIRED IN
RACING TODAY -- MOST INJURIES
ARE -- REPAIRED YOU KNOW FORCES
GO TO OTHER CAREERS TO GO TO THE
BREEDING CHAD -- SO THE THE
CATASTROPHIC INJURIES OR IN
ANOTHER WAY OF SAYING A FATAL
INJURIES SO -- THEY'RE STILL AT
RELATIVELY A SMALL PORTION OF
THE INJURIES THE ATHLETIC
INJURIES THAT OCCUR -- BUT THE
PROBLEM WITH FORCES IS THAT THEY
HAVE TO BE STANDING ON ALL ALL
FOUR LEGS -- IT ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY AFTER SURGERY SO IT
LIMITS YOUR ABILITY REPAIR SOME
FRACTURES -- AND IT ALSO WAS.
MY FINAL QUESTION APPEARS IT.
IT IN MANY COUNTRIES THAT
CONDUCT HORSE RACING RATES OF
COURSE TO TELL THESE ARE LOWER.
IT IN SOME INSTANCES MUCH LOWER.
THAN THE RATES EXPERIENCE IN THE
UNITED STATES DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON WHY THAT IS -- I I
WILL TELL YOU MY INTERNATIONAL
COLLEAGUES -- BELIEVE IT IS
BECAUSE OF ARE RELATIVELY
LIBERAL -- MEDICATION POLICIES
IN THE U. S. -- I'M NOT
CONVEYANCE IS SET SIMPLE WE HAVE
A CLAIMING OF GAME AYE AYE.
YOU HAVE TO GET IN THE INSIDE
BASEBALL BUT THERE ARE SOME
BUSINESS ASPECTS OF COURSE
RACING THAT PUT MORE STRESS ON
HORSES TO TREAT HIM A LITTLE BIT
MORE LIKE A COMMODITY.
THAN THEY DO INTERNATIONALLY --
WE'VE TRIED TO ELIMINATE SOME OF
THE NEGATIVE IN ST TEAMS FOR NOT
DOING RIGHT BY THE HORSE AND I
THINK WE'VE BEEN FAIRLY
SUCCESSFUL AT THAT -- THE ALSO
RECENT TURF -- IN MANY OF THE
EUROPEAN YOU -- OR INTERNATIONAL
JURISDICTIONS AS COMPARED DIRT
IN CALIFORNIA -- IN DIRT IS A
LESS FORGIVING SURFACED IN TURF.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
I GUESS OF THE I HAVE.
YOUR YOUR ANSWER -- MAYBE THING
ANOTHER QUESTION -- DO WE RACE
ALL YEAR ROUND HERE AND DO THEY
RACE ALL YEAR ROUND EVERYWHERE
ELSE -- THEY RACE YEAR ROUND IN
AUSTRALIA AND THAT'S ABOUT THE
ONLY MAJOR JURISDICTION THAT I'M
AWARE OF THE DOES -- TO EUROPE
IS -- SEASONAL -- HONG KONG HAS
ABOUT -- QUé -- SIX WEEKS BREAK.
IN FACT THIS BREAK FROM SANTA
NEED -- TO WHEN THEY WERE RE
WORKING THE RACETRACK IS THE
LARGEST BREAK THAT I CAN
REMEMBER IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RACING.
IN TWENTY FIVE YEARS OR MORE.
MISTER BECKER I GOT.
SAY IT'S MY FINAL ONE BUT I YOU
KNOW YOU BEEN CONNECTED RACING
YOU ALMOST YOUR ENTIRE LIFE --
IF YOU SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS
BEFORE THIS THIS.
SPIKE THAT -- THAT WE HAVE
WITNESSED ITS INUNDATED -- NO
NOT ANYTHING CLOSE THE THE ONLY
OTHER EXPERIENCE THAT I HAD WAS --
THE ONE I REFERENCED AT DEL MAR --
WERE NUMBER FORCES DURING THE
FIRST WEEK DOWN THERE -- WERE
LOST AND AS AS I SAID THAT LED
TO A NUMBER OF INITIATIVES THAT
CHANGED THINGS AND YOU KNOW WE
WERE GOING REALLY MAKING GREAT
PROGRESS GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
I IT WASN'T THIS WAY A LONG TIME
AGO -- BACK WHEN I WAS GROWING
UP IN THE SPORT -- AND I THINK
VERY SIMPLY THERE WERE MANY MORE.
FORCES INVOLVED IN RACING --
CALIFORNIA WAS A PRIME
OPPORTUNITY FOR A WORST RACE --
IF -- HORSE BECAME INJURED HERE --
YEAH.
PROBABLY YOU KNOW WENT ON THE
DISABLED LIST AND ANOTHER FRESH
HORSE WAS BROUGHT IN -- THERE
WERE ALMOST TWICE AS MANY FULLS
OF BACK THEN AS THERE ARE NOW --
SO THAT HAS STRESSED TO THE
RACING POPULATION WE WE DO REYES
DAY AND NIGHT NORTH AND SOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA -- WE HAVE ALMOST
FIVE THOUSAND HORSES.
IN NOT IN OUR CLOSURES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT INCLUDES CORE
WORSEN HARNESS RACING -- SO
THERE'S NO PRESSURE THAT THAT --
YOU KNOW FORCES ARE UNDER MORE
PRESSURE.
I WAS SO RELIEVED.
THE RUBIO YES THANK YOU -- I
JUST I I DID READ THE REPORT --
SOMEONE HANDED ME THEIR CAR FROM
THE JOCKEY CLUB IN A TALKS AT A
LOT ABOUT CHEATING IN THE
INDUSTRY SOME I CAN ASK THIS
QUESTION JUST BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW MAYBE YOU CAN HELP CLARIFY --
YOU FOR YOUR YOU STATED THAT
WHEN THE HEART GETS INJURED THE
MEDICAL RECORDS ARE GOING TO
FOLLOW NOW THAT THE HORSE.
AND I KNOW FOR US THERE'S STUFF
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE AS IT
PERTAINS TO KEEPING YOUR MEDICAL
RECORDS PRIVATE SO NO ONE CAN
ALTER THEM SO IS THERE ANYTHING
IN THE INDUSTRY THAT WOULD
PREVENT SOMEONE FROM CHANGING
THE RECORDS AND ALL TRAIN ANY.
THAT INFORMATION TO TRY AND
CHEAT THE SYSTEM.
NO I DON'T THINK SO AS A MATTER
OF FACT COURSE ANY OF THAT WOULD
ONCE DISCOVERED WOULD AMOUNT TO
A VIOLATION AND A COMPLAINT
FILED AND IN THE IF IT WAS A
VETERINARIAN. TO LOSE THE
ABILITY TO PRACTICE IN RACING IN
CALIFORNIA -- THERE IS A
PROVISION IN THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL LAW.
THAT SAYS THAT ANY OTHER STATE
JURISDICTION -- CAN REQUIRE AN
EXCEPTION TO THE PRIVACY.
LAW.
AND SO AS A RESULT WE ARE ABLE
TO REQUIRE THAT THE MEDICAL
RECORDS ARE TRANSFERRED WITH THE
HORSE.
THAT [inaudible]
THAT'S THANK YOU.
I WAS FOR YOU.
OTHER THAN THOSE FOR YOU THAT'S
A RELATIVELY NEW -- PROVISIONS
IN IN OUR RULES AND REX BUT
WE'RE GONNA BE SEEING MORE THAT --
AS WE GO FORWARD TO THE POINT
WHERE I THINK THAT WILL BE
COMMONPLACE THAT THE RECORDS
MOVE ALONG WITH THE HORSE FROM
START. TO THE END OF HIS CAREER
IS THERE ANY SYSTEM THAT'S BEEN
DEVELOPER IN PLACE THAT.
YOU CAN SHARE VIA THE INTERNET
OR THROUGH TECHNOLOGY VERSUS
PHYSICAL RECORDS AGAIN I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT SOME CHINA CD
CAN HELP EDUCATE ME ON THAT
DOCTOR ARE THERE'S BEEN WORKING
ON A PROGRAM WITH THE JOCKEY
CLUB THAT'S COINCIDENTAL TO THAT.
YEAH WHAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
A PROGRAM -- FOR SEVERAL YEARS
THAT WOULD ALLOW TREATMENT
RECORDS TO BE -- RECORDED
ELECTRONICALLY WE MAINTAIN NOW
NORMAIS BOXES OF HAND WRITTEN
HARD TO READ -- PAPER RECORDS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
ELECTRONICALLY RECORDED THAT
WOULD BE MORE AMENABLE TO EASY
TRANSFER MOST VETERINARY
PRACTICES ARE COMPUTERIZED TODAY.
SO THAT WERE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY WHERE THEY CAN TIE IN
THIS THE TWO SYSTEMS TOGETHER SO
THAT WOULD BE MORE.
USER FRIENDLY BUT I I WILL TELL
YOU THESE THINGS OR OR YOU SOUND
EASY BUT THEY'RE ALWAYS MORE
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU ACTUALLY GET
INTO TRYING. TO TO MASH UP
MULTIPLE -- COMPUTER PROGRAMS
TOGETHER BUT ONCE WE GET THERE
THEN THAT DATABASE WILL BE
SEARCHABLE.
AND RELATABLE.
SO WEEKEND THE EXPERTS THE
DOCTORS CAN'T DISCERN ANY KIND
OF PATTERNS ANY PARTICULAR
INCREASING USE OF A PARTICULAR
STE -- MEDICATION -- THAT MAY BE
APPROPRIATE MAYBE NOT.
AND SO WE OUR EXPERTS CAN BECOME
MORE EDUCATED AS TO WHAT IS
BEING USED.
BY THE VETERINARY COMMUNITY ON
THE BACKSIDE -- IT IS DOCTOR
ARTHUR SAID IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO DO NOW WITH THE OLD SCHOOL
METHOD OF REPORTING.
SO I HOPE TO SEE HAS GET THERE
THANK YOU.
IT'S A JOB FIRST AND THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
I THINK YOU'RE MY CHEN IS GERMAN --
I WALKED IN A LITTLE BIT LATE SO
I DON'T KNOW IF YOUR INCOME IS
BUT I HAVE.
TWO BASIC CATEGORIES OF IT OF A
QUESTION IS.
THE FIRST A CATEGORY OF THINGS
TO THE BECAUSE FOR THE DEBTS THE
MOTHER PUT THAT.
ON I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE WERE
SOME CONSULTANTS WHO WERE ON
SITE EXAMINING TO SURFACE -- AND
BECAUSE OF THE HEAVY RAIN THAT
OCCUR PRIOR TO SO OFFICE SO SO
QUESTION IS YOU KNOW WERE YOU
ABLE TO IDENTIFY THE CAUSE OR
CAUSES OF OF FOR THESE MULTIPLE
DEBTS.
AND OF THE SECOND CATEGORY OF OF
THE QUESTION IS -- I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE RACE TRACK LONG WAY TO
THE AIRPORT ALL ADOPTED A NUMBER
OF REFORMS INCLUDING THINGS LIKE --
THE PHASING OUT OF THE LEAST
SICK AND THE LIMITED USE OF THE
CROP ALSO THE SCANNING OF THE
HORSES A PRIOR TO US IN THE
LIGHT.
OF SO I WAS WONDERING IF OF DUES
MEASURES THOSE REFORM MEASURES
ALL WOULD DO IT THE TEAM
ADEQUATE FOR EXAMPLE TO AT LEAST
CARP THE THE SITUATION OR YOU
KNOW TO BASICALLY.
TO ADDRESS IT TO ME.
THE CRUX OF THE ISSUE COULD WE
ADDRESS THE SECOND ONE BECAUSE
WE HAVE AN EXPERT ON THE TRACKS
HERE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE RIGHT
FOR TODD SAID.
DRESSES SECOND WHEN YOU CAN ASK
THE FIRST QUESTION TO ANOTHER
PANEL.
THANK YOU.
YEAH SO IN TERMS OF WHAT WE USED
FROM THE INVESTIGATIONS -- I
EXPLAINED IN MY REMARKS THAT
THEIR ON GOING THERE WITH THESE
ARE ENHANCED INVESTIGATIONS THEY
INVOLVE A CH ARE BE SWORN
INVESTIGATOR.
AS WELL AS AN OFFICIAL
VETERINARIAN AS WELL AS A
STEWARD -- WE HAVE ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF THE INTERVIEWS
COMPLETED -- WE EXPECT TO HAVE
THEM ALL DONE IN THE NEXT FOUR
WEEKS OR SO -- AT THAT POINT
WE'LL LEAVE IT -- TO THE DOCTORS
LIKE DOCTOR ARTHUR THE OFFICIAL
VETERINARIANS TO EXAMINE TE
RESULTS OF THE NEW CROP SEES TO
HELP US INTERPRET THE ANSWERS
THAT WERE GIVEN IN THE
INTERVIEWS -- AND IT'S POSSIBLE
THEN THAT WE MIGHT DRAW SOME
CONCLUSIONS SOME COMMON THREAD.
IT'S NOT LIKELY FRANKLY BECAUSE
EACH HORSE IS DIFFERENT MAY HAVE
AT BREEZE KISSING CONDITIONS
SOME MAY HAVE BEEN CAUSED BY THE
FACT THAT THE THE EXTREME
WEATHER IN THE CONDITION OF THE
RACE TRACK WHICH IS IMPOSSIBLE.
TO BEYOND A DOUBT RIGHT BUT WE
CAN DRAW CONCLUSIONS BUT IT'S
TOO SOON IF YOU KNOW ALL THESE
INVESTIGATIONS.
AS I STATED I THINK YOU WERE
HERE WELL YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
BEING DONE IN COOPERATION WITH
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
SO THE VERY THOROUGH AND CAREFUL.
THE KIND OF TAKE AS LONG AS THEY
TAKE BUT ONCE THEY'RE DONE THEN
WE'LL BE ABLE TO EXAMINE THEM
MORE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
Q. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I
HAVEN'T HEARD YOU GUYS GO OVER
THE SPECIFICS LIKE WITH
DIFFERENT BREEDS I'VE I'M A
HORSE OWNER AND WE'VE GOT TO SEE
WALKERS WE'VE GOT ARABIANS WE'VE
GOT QUARTER HORSES AND I FEDERAL
REST BEFORE.
JUST FOR THE MEMBERS THAT DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
DIFFERENT STRUCTURE IN THE
BREEDS.
AND THE BONE STRUCTURE AND IN.
AND EVEN THE TEMPERAMENTS IF YOU
ALL WANT.
TO TOUCH ON THAT A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE I THINK SOME MEMBERS
THINK A HORSE IS A HORSE IS A
HORSE.
AND I I KNOW THERE'S A VERY VAST
DIFFERENCE -- BUT MAYBE TOUCHING
ON THAT BECAUSE I KNOW BONE
STRUCTURE IS A LOT DIFFERENT I
KNOW WHEN YOU DO INSURANCE
WRITING YOU DON'T START.
YOU DON'T GET HOME TILL THEIR
FIVE WITH THIS REASON ON THAT
TOO MOST ON DO A LOT BETTER --
THREE YOU KNOW IN THE DIFFERENT
SPORTS HAVE DIFFERENT TIME LINES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
IT SPECIFICALLY BASED ON THE
HORSE'S BREEDING IN THE BOND
STRUCTURES IN THOSE THINGS FOR
WHAT IS BETTER SO CAN YOU GUYS
TOUCH ON THAT A LITTLE BIT.
JUST TO KIND OF INFORMED.
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
IT'S ACTUALLY -- GETS INTO SOME
PRETTY SERIOUS BONE PHYSIOLOGY
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT TRAINING
THROUGH A BROWSER LINK OUT
ANYWHERE BUT THEY THEIR THEIR
BONES ACTUALLY RESPOND -- TO
TRAINING -- IN THE HORSES OF
COURSE ARE BORN WITH RESOURCE
SKELTON'S THEY HAVE TO ADAPT AND
TRAINING DOES THAT AND IT JUST
SO HAPPENS THAT THE YOUNGER AGES --
THE BONE ADAPTS MORE CAREFULLY
GET STRONGER GET STRONG ENOUGH
TO BE AT A RATE SOURCING FACTORS
DATA THAT SHOWS THAT THE LATER
OR TO START -- THE MORE RISKS
THEY ARE FOR INJURY.
SO COURSES WORDS LIKE A RACE CAR
THERE THEY HAVE IS LIGHT A BONUS
WE POSSIBLY CAN TO CARRY THAT.
HEAVY WEIGHT AROUND THE
RACETRACK -- STANDARDBRED
SWITCHER TROTTERS OR A LITTLE
BIT HAVE YOUR BILL THERE'S MORE
STYLE -- AND THEY'RE BIGGER GAIN
CLEAR HORSES FOR THE MOST PART
EVEN THOUGH YOU CAN GET HIM ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
AND QUARTER HORSES ARE MOSTLY
THOROUGHBREDS TODAY BUT THERE'S
SORT OF THE SPRINTER TYPES OR
THE THE THE FULL BACK TYPE OF OF
OF COURSES IN THEIR THEIR
STOUTER THEY'RE STRONGER AND
THEY GIVE.
A ENORMOUS BURST OF SPEED FOR A
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
SO IT IS THAT WHAT YOU WERE
LOOKING.
FOR YEAH BUT I MEAN I I KNOW THE
DIFFERENCES BUT I DON'T KNOW FOR
MY COLLEAGUES NECESSARILY DO SO
CALLED ROLLERS ARE THE ONES WE
SEE IN THE RODEOS.
JUST MAYBE EDUCATING.
MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES ON ON THAT
MIGHT BE BENEFICIAL FOR YOU ALL
YEAH THEY THEY THE DIFFERENCES
ARE A I I DON'T WORK I I DON'T
WORK MUCH WITH RODEO HORSES AND
AND THE LIGHT.
BUT YOU KNOW THEY'RE EIGHT
DIFFERENT HORSES AFTER FOR USES
WE DO HAVE THE DRAFT HORSES AT
SANTA ANITA THEY USED TO PULL
THE GATE AND THEY'RE STILL THERE
FOR FOR THE PUBLIC TO LOOK AT IN
THEIR BEER VERY HEAVY STYLE
HORSES.
BONES ARE ARE IS BIG IS AROUND
IS MOST PEOPLE'S LEGS AND THEY
JUST GO VERY SLOW WHEN THEY'RE
VERY STRONG AND THEY THEY NEVER
GET INTO PROBLEMS -- BUT
THOROUGHBRED STATE ARE VERY HIGH
CAN ANY SPORTS STATE THE ANIMALS
THEY LOVE TO RUN -- THEY'RE VERY
COMPETITIVE -- THEY BURNED BRED
TO BE COMPETITIVE IN THE RUN
FAST FIRST THREE HUNDRED PLUS
YEARS.
SO -- YOU KNOW THEY THY DO
ENJOY DOING WHAT THEY DO -- AND
YOU CAN ACTUALLY SEE THE
DIFFERENCE WHEN THEY'RE THEY'RE
FAT AS COMPARED TO WHEN THEY'RE
TURNED OUT.
BUT THERE'S ALL DIFFERENT SIZES
LIKE IS THAT WE EVEN HAVE MANY
WORSE -- FORCES ON THE BACKSIDE
THEIR PANTS.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU --
DOCTORS ARTHUR AND THE KITCHEN
IS A LOTS OF THAT RIGHT THIS
DOES CORRECT YES THANK YOU BOTH.
FOR BEING HERE MISTER BOEDEKER
AND MISS OUR BACK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR EXPERTISE AND YOUR
ALL OF YOU.
THANK THANK YOU.
OKAY WE ARE GOING TO STE STE
SHIFT HERE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO THE THIRD PANEL BECAUSE WE
HAVE A COUPLE THAT NEED TO LEAVE --
SO I WOULD LIKE -- NOW TO PULL
UP THE PARTICIPATES PERSPECTIVE
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME -- TERREL
HERE THE WESTERN REGIONAL
MANAGER OF THE JOCKEYS GUILD
MIKE SMITH NATIONAL MUSEUM OF
RACING IN ALL THREE INDUCTEE AND
WRITER OF JUSTIFY THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TRIPLE CROWN
WINNER.
BOB BAFFERT THOROUGHBRED TRAINER
AND WINNER TO TRIPLE CROWNS AS
WELL AS FIVE KENTUCKY DERBYS.
IT GERRY FENTON RACEHORSE OWNER
AND RACING AFFAIRS CHAIRMAN OF
THE THOROUGHBRED OWNERS
[inaudible]
CALIFORNIA.
SINCE WE HAVE SO MANY WHAT I
LIKE TO DO IF WE COULD ASK IS
KEEP YOUR COMMENT SHORTEN LET'S --
SEE IF WE GET DIRECT SOME --
QUESTION.
BRADFORD WE'LL START WITH YOU.
THERE WE GO.
I WANT TO THANK A YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO SPEAK THIS
AFTERNOON I'M HERE BEFORE YOU.
BECAUSE I LOVE OUR STATE.
I LOVE -- RATIONING CALIFORNIA.
MY BASE OF OPERATIONS IS HERE MY
FAMILY IS HERE.
I LIVE HERE.
IN OUR INDUSTRY IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR SO MANY JOBS SO MANY
FAMILIES AND MOST IMPORTANTLY SO
MANY LOVED HORSES -- WE LOVE
THEM AND CARE FOR THEM DEEPLY I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH.
WITH YOU TO RESTORE THE
CONFIDENCE IN RACINE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IF WE DON'T
WE ALL LOSE.
AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
INVITATION SPEAKER.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THAT'S HELLO ONE MIKE SMITH THE
HALL OF FAME JOCKEY.
I HAVE A BIG LONG SPEECHES THAT
I WAS GONNA READ BUT THEN JUST
TO MAKE IT THE TO MAKE IT SHORT.
YOU KNOW THERE RISK FACTORS IN
IN ALL SPORTS AS WE ALL KNOW.
IN COUNTY COMBINING THAT WITH
THE WEATHER THAT WE GOT A FEW
MONTHS AGO -- JUST KIND HIS ALL
AT ONCE -- BUT I CAN HONESTLY
TELL YOU THAT THAT.
THE RIGHT NOW AFTER THIRTY YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE THAT THE I FEEL
MORE SAFE RIGHT IN A SANTA NINO
OR DEL MAR FOR THAT MATTER OF A
THAN I'VE EVER.
FELT IT RIGHT IN A RACE TRACK
EVER IN MY LIFE TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU.
IF YOU GAVE ME TWO MORE RACES
PROVIDED BY THE B. AT SENATE AND
TOMORROW.
HELLO CALIFORNIA REASON I CAN
MOVE MY TECH ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD ACTUALLY AND I WOULD MOVE
IT FOR FOR ALL THE MONEY IN THE
WORLD BE HONEST WITH YOU.
HELLO RACING HERE I KNOW THAT
THE SENATE HAS DONE A HECK OF A
JOB TO REALLY GET THIS THING
BACK RIGHT AGAIN AND WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT STAYS RIGHT
[inaudible]
ON PART OF OF OF MY WHAT I DO AS
FAR AS A RACE RIDER IN USING THE
RIGHT PROPERTY IT'S COMING UP.
I CAN ASSURE THE PUBLIC IN AND
YOU SIT IN HERE THAT WE HAVE THE
MOST EQUINE FRIENDLY RIDING
CROPS IN THE WORLD.
I MEAN THERE'S EQUINE AND HUMAN
FRIENDLY TO BE TO BE A FACT --
THEIR INCREDIBLE WE HAVE
DISTRICT IS RIDING CROP -- SAGE
IN THE WORLD I MEAN WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE TOUGH ON IT.
IN WE TAKE PRIDE IN IN IN DOING
THE RIGHT THING BY THE HORSE YOU
KNOW HORSES ALWAYS COME FIRST --
WHEN IT COMES TO THE RACE TRACK --
AND THAT THAT'S IN ANY INDEED
I'D RATHER BE AN OWNER TRAINER
OR JOCKEY WELL IN THE RACE TRACK
FOR THAT MATTER.
BUT ANYWAY I'M JUST HERE TO TO
TELL YOU THAT I LOVE CALIFORNIA
RACING IS THE BEST REASON.
IT'S FAR AS I'M CONCERNED IN THE
WORLD AND I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE
AND OPEN ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE A AFTERWARDS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
THEY'RE ALL HEREON THE WEST AND
REGIONAL MANAGER FOR THE JOCKEYS
GUILD.
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THE GUILD
IN.
NINETEEN FORTY THE GUILD IS WHAT
HI ASHLEY FOR THE SAFETY AND
WELFARE OUT THERE READING
QUARTER HORSE RACING -- JOCKEYS
IN THE UNITED STATES.
WE AT WORK WITH INDUSTRY.
WITH THE INDUSTRY A NUMBER OF
ISSUES INCLUDING HELMET SAFETY
VEST SAFETY RAIL SAFETY RAINS
RACE THEY MEDICATION DRUG
TESTING INCREASING THIS GALA
WAIT.
PRE RACE EXAMS DESIGNATION OF
TRAUMA SAN IS REGULATION OF
SHOCK WAVE THERAPY IN CONCUSSION
PROTOCOLS.
WITH RETURN TO RIDE GUIDELINES.
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE.
HEALTH INSURANCE PROGRAM THAT
WAS ESTABLISH WHICH PROVIDES
SUBSIDIZED FULL FAMILY HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE FOR ACTIVE AND
RETIRED RIGHT IS.
LEGISLATION WHICH PROVIDES THE
PENSION PLAN FOR JACKIE'S FUNDED
IN PART BY WAGES PLACE ON THE
INTERNET.
AND LOSING MOUNT FEES INCREASES
THAT A LINK TO INCREASES IN THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE ADDITIONALLY
THE GUILD WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
CALIFORNIA'S.
ADAPTATION OF A THREE STRIKE.
RIDING CROP -- WHICH IS THE MOST
STRINGENT USE USAGE RULE IN THE
COUNTRY.
THE GUILD HAS BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR AMBULANCES TO BE CALLING THE
FEELS IN FOR THEM TO BE PROPERLY
STAFFED WITH AT LEAST ONE
PARAMEDIC IN FULLY EQUIPPED.
FOLLOWING THE DEATH OF A JOCKEY
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE THE GUILD
SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATED FOR THE
C. H. OUT BE TO REQUIRE THAT
TRACK MANAGEMENT.
STAFF IT'S TRACKED AMBULANCE
WITH A PARAMEDIC.
IN SHORT IN MANY WAYS CALIFORNIA
IS THE GOLD STANDARD FOR RACING
JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY -- I FEEL AS MIKE THAT.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE IN AND
HAVE PUT IN PLACE IN WORKING
WITH THE COMMISSION OVER THE
YEARS.
SOME SOME OF THE SAFEST.
IN MADE IT THAT SAFE AS
ENVIRONMENT FOR JOCKEYS HERE.
WE WORKED WITH THE COMMISSION --
OVER THE YEARS WITH THE THE
RIDING CROP WHEN WE CHANGE TO
THE QUESTION CRAP.
IN IMPLEMENTED THAT IT DOWN MY
YEARS AGO -- THEN WE IMPLEMENTED
THE THREE STRIKE RULE THAT'S
WORKED REALLY WELL AND WE FEEL
NOW WITH THE ADDITION OF THE
THREE SIXTY RIDING CROP.
THAT IT'S BEEN MORE SAFER AND
KIND AT THE TOP RIGHT.
SO WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMISSION FOR THE GOOD OF THE
GAME -- THE GUILD IS ADVOCATING
SAFETY AT ALL WHATEVER WE CAN DO.
TO HELP IN ANY WAY WITH THEIR
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS GERRY
FENTON.
AND THE MANAGING PARTNER OF LARA
FEATHER RACING I AM ALSOTHE
RATE CHAIR OF THE RACING AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE FOR THE THOROUGHBRED
OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA.
THE TO YOU SEE REPRESENTS THE
THREE THE SEVEN THOUSAND PLUS
MEMBERS WHO RACE IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR MEMBERS OWN TRAINING CARE
FOR THE THIRD RENTS A COMPETE
FROM THE BAY AREA DEL MAR.
START FROM WHERE I SAID OUR
HORSES RECEIVE EXTRAORDINARY
LEVELS OF CARE.
THERE TENDED TO AND MONITOR
DAILY BY TRAINERS EXERCISE
WRITER'S PERSONAL ROOMS PRIVATE
AND REGULATORY VETERINARIANS.
THEIR DIETS EXERCISE AND DAILY
REGIMEN ARE CAREFULLY OVERSEEN
BY EQUINE PROFESSIONALS THEY'RE
SUBJECT TO PRE AND POST RACE
EXAMINATIONS AND TESTING.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO CREATING AND
PAYING FOR THE SAFE AS A VARMINT
POSSIBLE FOR THESE ATHLETES TO
RAISE AND TRAIN.
IN ALMOST INCIDENTS OF SERIOUS
INJURIES AT ST YOU THIS WINTER
SERVES AS A REMINDER WE CAN
ALWAYS STRIVE TO IMPROVE AND
ENHANCE OUR EFFORTS TO MAKE
THINGS SAFER FOR HORSES.
THAT'S WHY WE'VE ENDORSED REFORM
MEASURES RECENTLY PUT IN PLACE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT OFFER ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS THE HORSE AND RIDER
INCLUDING WE'RE RAMPING TRAINING
PROTOCOLS TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
THAT NERI CHECKS.
AND SAFEGUARDS REDUCTION FACED
ELIMINATION OF RACE DAY
MEDICATION AND MORE STRINGENT
GUIDELINES ON THE USE OF THE
RIDING CROP.
WE BELIEVE THESE REFORMS WILL
REDUCE THE INCIDENCE OF SERIOUS
INJURY.
EVERY INDUSTRY GO THROUGH
DIFFICULT PERIODS MANY PEOPLE
SITTING HERETODAY ROSE TO THE
CHALLENGE DURING THIS TIME AND
THE EARLY RESULTS ARE POSITIVE.
WE HOPE THIS IS ONLY A START.
WITH THE RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT OF
THE PET SCANS IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS CONTEMPLATING
ADOPTION OF OUR NEW ROLES
BECAUSE ME HOPE.
THAT THE HORSE RACING INDUSTRY
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY IS
COMMITTED TO DOING WHATEVER IT
TAKES TO INCREASE SAFETY
GUIDELINES TO THE HIGHEST LEVELS
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU -- QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU FOR
COMING BEFORE US TODAY -- COULD
YOU REFER TO THE THREE STRIKE
RULE CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO THREE
STRIKE RULE IS.
THAT'S MY FIRST QUESTION.
AND THEN THE SECOND OKAY.
IN THE SECOND QUESTION I WILL BE
WHAT DO YOU THINK OR WHAT COULD
WE DO TO TRY -- TO ASSIST AND
HELP IN THIS EFFORT.
OFFER SOMEONE WHO GREW UP IN LOS
ANGELES -- WHO TRAVEL WITH MY MY
DADDY WHO WENT -- TO HOLLYWOOD
PARK AND I HAD AND I GREW --
FONDNESS OF THE HORSE INDUSTRY
AS A RESULT OF THAT -- WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY CONTINUES OTHER
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S IT'S
BETTER FOR ALL.
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED SO WHAT CAN
WE DO IT IN ORDER TO HELP MAKE
IT BETTER I'M AS A STATE I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO SOME OF YOUR
SUGGESTIONS AND THEN PLEASE
EXPLAIN A THREE STRIKE RULE.
TO LIST THE THREE STRIKE RULE IS
IS.
YOU. THREE STRIKES IF YOU NEED
THEN YOU HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT TO GIVE A HORSE A
CHANCE TO RESPOND YOU CAN'T JUST
KEEP KEEP WRITING THEM.
AGAIN IT HAS TO BE WITH THE WITH
THE MANDATORY CUSHION CROP.
WHICH IF YOU'VE EVER SEEN ONE OF
YOU EVER SEEN WHEN YOU CAN FEEL
IS A LOT LIKE A NERF -- THING SO
IT MAKES A LOT OF NOISE IN THE
CRAP IS USED FOR FOR SEVERAL
DIFFERENT REASONS I MEAN FIRST
OF ALL SAFETIES IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT REASONS THAT IS
USED FOR BUT YOU KNOW REALLY HE
KEEPS ALL YOU CAN YOU CAN
ENCOURAGE A HORSE.
IN A SAFE MANNER.
YOU CAN KEEP HIM FOCUSED AS YOU
SAW IN THE KENTUCKY DERBY HORSES
DON'T ALWAYS WANT TO RUN
STRAIGHT SO IT ALSO HELPS SHE
GUIDED TIMES BUT IT'S IT'S IS
THE NECESSARY TOOL THAT WE
REALLY REALLY REALLY HAVE TO
HAVE.
AND AS FAR AS WHAT WE CAN DO
BETTER OF THESE PRE RACE EXAMS --
WHATEVER WE COULD DO IS A WRITER --
IN ON POLICING OURSELVES IN AND
AND LET EACH OTHER KNOW THAT IF
SOMETHING DOESN'T FEEL QUITE
RIGHT.
YOU KNOW JUST TO HEAD STRAIGHT
OVER TO THAT NEVER ENDS YOU KNOW
AND AND AND NOT TAKING ANY ANY
RISK AND IT'S RISKY ENOUGH AS IT
IS BUT WE CAN ALL DO BETTER
WE'RE ALL GONNA WORK HARDER AT
IT -- AND AND WE'VE BEEN DOING
SO I MEAN TRUST ME MY LIFE ON
THE LINE EVERY TIME I GO OUT
THERE AND I I'M NOT GOING TO GO
OUT THERE UNLESS I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT THAT IS SAFE AND AND LIKE I
STATED EARLIER I HONESTLY FEEL
NOW THAT I I RIDE.
IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT THAN I
EVER DID WHEN I FIRST UNDER
RIGHT NOW BEEN GOING THIRTY
YEARS.
WHAT CAN WE DO BETTER WHAT CAN
WHAT CAN STATE DUE TO HELP?
AND ASSISTANCE EFFORT.
A SECOND SIR WHAT CAN THE STATE
DO. TO HELP.
WAS FOR IS IS.
IT A LOT OF THAT WOULD BE BOB
COMPLAINTS OF A LITTLE BETTER
FOR YOU BUT AS FAR AS A WRITER
AND AND WHAT WHAT WHAT WE COULD
DO IS.
WE'RE WE'VE BEEN PRETTY HAPPY
WITH WHAT WE'VE WHAT WE'VE DONE
BUT WE NEED TO WORK MORE WITH
WITH WITH VETERINARIANS AS FAR
AS IS IS PRE PRE RACE --
EXAMINATIONS YOU KNOW IT AND WE
WERE WARMING UP IN THE POST
PARADE MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYTHING'S RIGHT AND IF
THERE'S SOME OTHER MIDDLE
STRONGER RULES THEY NEED TO PUT
IN THE WE'RE WE'RE WILLING TO
WORK WITH ANYTHING THAT YOU NEED
TO DO.
SO IS A VETERINARIAN.
ON SITE.
YES SIR.
AND THE CHECK OUT THE HORSES
BEFORE THE CONVERTED NORTH
DISINTEGRATE YES SO THERE IS A
MATTER OF FACT A LOT OF TIMES
ESPECIALLY ON ON YOU KNOW DERBY
DAYS OR EVEN REDUCE COMPANIES
THERE'S THERE'S FOUR FIVE OF
THEM ON SITE.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA AYE AYE RACE
ALL OVER THE UNITED STATES IN
CALIFORNIA IS PROBABLY THE MOST
REGULATED STATE I MEAN WE REALLY.
I MEAN WE GO THE THESE HORSES
THEY HAVE TO JUMP.
A JUMP THROUGH A LOT OF HOOPS
BEFORE THEY GET THAT STERN GAME
[inaudible]
AND AND SO IT'S IT'S IT'S REALLY
WHAT HAPPENED THIS WINTER LIKE
I'M VERY FORTUNATE I DIDN'T HAVE
ANY ISSUES WELCOME WOULD BUT YOU
KNOW YOU YOU JUST NEVER KNOW
WHEN IT MIGHT HAPPEN YOU KNOW.
THIS HORSE IS THE YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES IT CAN AND SOMETIMES
THEY DON'T YOU KNOW SOMETHING
HAPPENS AND SO -- I I JUST
REALLY I WAS LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE
OF K<c.cyan> HAPPENING AND I KNOW</c>
THE WEATHER YOU KNOW PLAYED A
BIG PART IN IT.
BUT IT WAS -- YOU KNOW I WAS YOU
KNOW I I'VE ONE MIGHT TO TRIPLE
CROWN HORSES TRAINED ON THAT
SAME SERVICE YOU KNOW I'VE NEVER
AND MARK DERBY HORSES I MEAN
CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRST POP FOUR OUT OF FIVE
WITH THE DERBY FAVORITE AND
THEY'D ALL TRAIN IT'S AND THE
THE THIS WINTER SO.
IT WAS JUST SOMETHING NOT ON I
CAN'T SPEAK.
WITH THE WHY -- BUT IT WAS
UNFORTUNATE BUT I REALLY THINK
WITH EVERYTHING THEY PUTTING IN
PLACE NOW I THINK.
I THINK THE TRAINERS AGAIN DO A
BETTER JOB POLICING THEMSELVES
EVERYBODY I MEAN.
YOU KNOW THIS IS BEEN -- OF IT'S
BEEN SOME ON HARD TIMES YOU KNOW
GOING THROUGH US AND NEED A ITS
MOST BEAUTIFUL.
TRACK IN THE IN THE COUNTRY AND
IS IT'S IT'S A SHAME THAT WAS
PUT IT'S BEEN UNDER THIS KIND OF
SCRUTINY.
THANK YOU CENTER RUBIO.
THE HOUSE THE FIRST QUESTION BUT
I'M SORRY I MISSED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK THE FIRST --
HELLO BUT MAYBE YOU CAN ANSWER
THIS I'M A LITTLE CURIOUS ABOUT
THE MAKEUP OF THE BOARD.
THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD I ANOTHER SEVEN MEMBERS
CAN YOU TELL ME THERE'S ANY
EXPERTS ON THE BOARD AS IT
PERTAINS TO THE TO THE INDUSTRY.
HAVE RACE BEFORE JOCKEYS ANYBODY
THAT HAS THAT KIND OF DEPTH OF
KNOWLEDGE.
YEAH YES THERE IS ACTUALLY --
THERE'S A JOB THESE NAMES ALEX
LEASES ON THE BOARD AS WELL.
BUT A LOT OF THE BOARD MEMBERS
ARE OWNERS OF RESOURCES -- I'M
NOT TOO SURE IF THERE'S A
TRAINER ON THE BOARD.
I'M SURE THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
IN THE PAST BUT BUT I'M NOT SURE
THERE IS RIGHT NOW BUT BUT A LOT
OF OUR OUR OWNERS IN IN -- THERE
IS ONE ONE JACQUI THIS ON THE
BOARD.
THINKING OUT HOW TO CHANGE UP
INTO THE IN MATTER OF FACT.
I THINK IT'S REMEMBER CHAO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF I COULD
FOLLOW UP -- ON MISTER GIBSON'S
QUESTION SO CURRENTLY.
ON THE HORSES ARE BEING EXAMINED
BY THE VET ON THE DAY OF THE
RACE WARS PRIOR TO HOW SOON
BEFORE THE THE RACING -- OCCURS
BEFORE THE THEIR OF THEIR
THEY'RE EXAMINED -- THE MORNING
OF THE RACE.
WE GET ABOUT.
AND WE JARGON BACK AND FORTH
YEAH.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN TELL THE
HORSE'S GAIT IF THEY'RE HOW THEY
FEEL AND AND THESE VETS THAT
THAT ACTUALLY THAT THAT ARE
EXAMINING.
THEY KNOW MOST OF THE HORSES
THEY HAVE NOTES ON EVERY HORSE
IF THERE'S ANY CHANGE AT ALL
THEY MAKE A NOTE OF IT.
SO THERE ITS THIRD THERE UNDER A
LOT OF SCRUTINY SOURCES SO --
AND YOU DON'T SEE THAT ANYWHERE
OF ME CALIFORNIA IS WHERE IT
GETS REALLY TOUGH.
FOR THAT'S WHY I WAS VERY
SURPRISING WHAT'S GOING ON THIS
WINTER AND SO -- IT'S ACTUALLY --
IT'S PRETTY.
YOU KNOW STRICT RULES WE HAVE.
THE NEED TO ADMINISTER LATELY
SICK FOR EXAMPLE WHEN DOES THAT --
CAN ADMINISTER.
HELLO DEBTS IN MINISTERED BY A
THIRD PARTY BY THIS.
STATE APPOINTED -- BATS -- THAT
THE MINISTER FOR HOURS PRIOR.
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT YOU KNOW THE TIMING OF THE
EXAMINATION OF THE HORSES BEFORE
THE THE THE THE HORSES BEING RUN
SO.
SO WHETHER THAT'S YOU KNOW
APPROPRIATELY SPACED OUT -- THE
EMINEM AROUND PROBABLY AROUND.
YOU KNOW EIGHT O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING PROBABLY THAT DAY.
THANK YOU.
CENTER BRADFORD YES I'M SURE
SAID I MISS IT HOW MANY HORSES
RUNNING CALIFORNIA I OR OR RUN
ON A ANNUAL BASIS I THINK LAST
YEAR THERE WERE AS BETWEEN FIVE
AND SIX THOUSAND THOROUGHBREDS.
OKAY AND OF THAT FIVE SIX
THOUSAND HOW MANY INJURIES DID
YOU HAVE WASHER.
I THINK THAT'S A QUESTION FOR
THE C. H. EVERITT ON TAX ARE.
AND I I JUST WANT TO THINK ARMS
BRADFORD AND THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
GAVE ME TO OUR NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO.
SENATE NEED TO AND I TOTALLY
AGREE I WAS.
THOROUGHLY IMPRESSED -- I GREW
UP RIDING HORSES BUT I LEARNED
SO MUCH THAT DAY AND HA.
IT'S ONE THING I KNOW FOR SURE
THAT SAFETY OF THE HORSES AND
SAFETY OF THE JOCKEYS ARE
PARAMOUNT ON EVERYTHING THAT I
SAW IN NEW FARM AND IT WAS.
AMAZING SHOW -- AS A LEGISLATOR
WE DEFINITELY WANT TO PRESERVE
THIS INDUSTRY FOR SURE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S UNIQUE IN ITS --
SPECIAL -- I AT HOLLYWOOD PARK
IN MIGHT TWO STRICKEN WITH NO
LONGER HAVE THAT RACETRACK SO --
BUT WHATEVER WE CAN DO.
TO GUARANTEE ANIMAL AND JOCKEY
SAFETY IS PARAMOUNT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS BUT AGAIN
ON YOU GUYS ARE THE EXPERTS --
ARE WE CAN ASSIST AND I THINK
MISTER BAFTA CHIP ON
CALIFORNIA'S THE MOST REGULATED.
STATE IN ANY INDUSTRY SO WELCOME
TO THE CLUB OF JEAN OVER
REGULATE OUR THE OTHER QUESTIONS.
XENA GENTLEMAN IT MAY HAVE BEEN
SHORT DURATION BUT WE GOT A LOT
OF GREAT INFORMATION FROM YOU.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE YOU COMING
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER -- NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO THE
SECOND GROUP WHICH IS.
THIS IS GONNA BE ON THE SCENE IN
THE TO UPDATE PRACTICES MOVING
FORWARD.
BLOOM DISTRAUGHT AGE -- CHAIRMAN
OF IT PRESIDENT OF THE STROLLER
GROUP.
I A DOCTOR DION BENSON CHIEF
BENNETT VETERINARIAN OFFICER FOR
THIS PRODUCT GROUP.
IN ONE TO BE NAMED LATER.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD EVENING --
MY NAME IS BELINDA STRONACH I'M
THE CHAIRMAN AND THE PRESIDENT
OF DESTROYING A GROUP.
PLEASE ACCEPT MY APOLOGIES FOR
MY MY VOICE I I DID A LITTLE BIT
TOO MUCH TALKING ON THE WEEKEND.
AS WE HOSTED THE PREAKNESS --
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR INVITING US HERE TODAY.
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A LIMITED --
TIME TO SPEAK BUT WE'RE VERY
PROUD.
OF SOME OF THE CHANGES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED MOST RECENTLY AT SANTA
ANITA.
WORKING TOGETHER WITH OUR
INDUSTRY PARTNERS WITH THE TOC.
WITH THE CITY TO THE TRAINERS
WITH THE JOCKEYS.
AND ALSO WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
C. H. R. B..
WITH ME HERE IS OUR WHO -- AN
EXECUTIVE WHO USUALLY CHOI WHO
JUST JOINED US --
INTERNATIONALLY RENOWNED
VETERINARIAN -- EXPERT -- DR
DEANE BENSON.
AND ALSO THE PRESIDENT OR RACING
DIVISION MIKE ROGERS
[inaudible]
SO.
I'M ONE OF THE BELIEVERS THAT
THE HORSE RACING IS REALLY THE
LAST GREAT SPORTING LEGACY
PLATFORM.
THAT REALLY NEEDS TO MODERNIZE.
AND WHEN I FIRST FOLLOWED IN THE
FOOTSTEPS OF OUR FAMILY BUSINESS.
MY FOCUS WAS REALLY ABOUT.
HOW DO WE TURN AROUND THIS
INDUSTRY THAT IS DECLINING?
IN POPULARITY AND HOW DO WE
ATTRACT NEW GUESTS AND NEW FANS
TOUR SUPPORT.
SO MY FOCUS WAS REALLY ABOUT.
THE GUEST EXPERIENCE HOW WE CAN
ENHANCE THAT HOW WE CAN
MODERNIZE OUR FACILITIES HOW WE
CAN CURATE A COMPELLING.
ENTERTAINMENT OFFERING OF WHICH
HORSE RACING AND WAGERING IS AT
THE CORE.
AND YOU KNOW APPLYING TECHNOLOGY
AS WELL AND NEW FORMS OF
WAGERING IN BETTER.
BUT AS I GOT MORE INTO IT AND
THEN TOGETHER WITH THE WITH THE
VERY UNFORTUNATE SERIES OF
EVENTS.
WAS RECENTLY AT SANTA ANITA.
MY FOCUS IN TOGETHER WITH OUR
MANAGEMENT TEAM TURN TO THE
INJURIES AND THE CATASTROPHIC
INJURIES AT SANTA ANITA.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
THAT TO OF THOSE LESS FAMILIAR
WITH OUR WITH OUR INDUSTRY IN
OUR SPORT.
THE STRONG GROUP IN SANTA NEED
AND ALSO GOLDEN GATE FIELD HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE THE
PLATFORM.
AND WE ARE ALSO A STAKEHOLDER
INDUSTRY THAT MEANS WE NEED THE
JOCKEYS WE NEED THE TRAINERS WE
NEED THE HORSE OWNERS WE NEED
THE VETERINARIANS.
AND WE NEED EVERYBODY TO WORK
TOGETHER. TO TO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS STAKEHOLDERS QUIRK
[inaudible]
REALLY WORKS.
AND WITH THE WITH WHAT HAPPENED --
IN THE RECENT MONTHS WITH THE
INCREASING THE CATASTROPHIC
ENERGY ENTRIES WHAT WE DID IS WE
SAID WE NEED TO LOOK AT THIS
ENTIRE ECOSYSTEM.
THAT MAKES UP OUR SPORT AND
RACING AT SANTA ANITA.
AS WE WERE IN THE PROCESS OF
DOING THAT AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT I THINK BOB BAFFERT HAD TO
LEAVE.
BUT HE WAS IN A VERY DIFFICULT
POSITION WHERE HE WAS ONE
MORNING GIVING AN INTERVIEW --
WITH FOX TELEVISION LIVE.
AND WE SUDDENLY HAD ANOTHER
CATASTROPHIC INJURIES.
AND THAT WAS A VERY DEVASTATING
MOMENT FOR EVERYONE THAT WITNESS
TO THAT MOMENT.
AS AN EXECUTIVE TEAM WITH AND
SAID LOOK WE REALLY HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING NOW.
THAT DEMONSTRATES THAT WE HAVE
REALLY TO HAVE COURSE WELFARE
AND WRITER WILL FOR AT THE
CENTER.
OF EVERYTHING THAT WE DO.
IT WAS IN MID MARCH THAT WE
ISSUED THAT OPEN LETTER. TO THE
PUBLIC THAT STATED WHAT OUR
INTENTIONS WERE.
AND THAT WILL GO INTO THAT IN A
MINUTE.
I THINK WHAT MOST IMPORTANT WHAT.
BUT THAT THOSE REFORMS OF WHAT.
WHAT WHAT THAT LED TO IS?
I BELIEVE CALIFORNIA RACING IS
NOW THE SAFEST IN NORTH AMERICA.
WE HAVE MOVED TO INTERNATIONAL
STANDARDS ON ALL.
OTHER CONSISTENT WITH OR BETTER
THAN INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS.
EXCEPT FOR LASIX.
AND WE ARE ADVOCATING FOR A
PHASE OUT OF LASIX.
AND WE'VE STATED THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY ALL TWO YEAR
OLDS WILL BEGIN TO RUN WITHOUT
LASIX.
AND FOR THE DURATION OF THEIR
CAREERS WILL NOT HAVE LASIX
WE'VE ALSO COMMITTED TO STAKES
RACES.
BEING LASIX FREE SO IT IS MY
HOPE THAT IN BY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FOUR OR TWENTY FIVE THAT
WE WILL NO LONGER HAVE FORCES
RUNNING ON LASIX.
WE'VE DONE A NUMBER OF OTHER
THINGS.
THAT ARE I BELIEVE WE'RE SEEING
SOME OF THE POSITIVE OUTCOMES AS
IT RELATES TO THE PROTOCOLS MUCH
MORE STRINGENT PROTOCOLS.
REGARDING WHICH HORSES TRAINED
AT OUR FACILITIES.
AND FOR EXAMPLE HAVING TO SIGN
UP FORTY EIGHT HOURS IN ADVANCE
WILL WORK OUT.
MEANS THAT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
CAN IS THERE FOR THE
INTERVENTION.
IN CASE THERE ARE SOME COURSES
THAT MAY NEED THAT EXTRA
INTERVENTION WHERE WE TAKE A
SECOND LOOK AT IS THAT OF COURSE.
TRULY FIT TO TRAIN.
WE ALSO MADE THE COMMITMENT TO
UP MAKE AVAILABLE STATE OF THE
ART DIAGNOSTIC EQUIPMENT.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT MANY OF
THE OWNERS AND TRAINERS ARE
UNAWARE OF SOME OF THE INJURIES
THAT THEIR HORSES MAY HAVE SOME
OF THOSE PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS.
SO TRUE TO OUR COMMITMENT OF
WHAT WE STATED WE HAVE INVESTED
IN THE ACQUISITION OF A P. E.
T.'S CAM WHICH DOCTOR BENSON CAN
SPEAK.
OF MUCH MORE KNOWLEDGE
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT THAN THAN I
CAN -- THE OTHER THING THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT AND HOW DO WE
ENHANCE THE TRIAGE PROGRAM.
WHEN THERE IS AN INJURY ON THE
TRACK THAT THERE IS AN IMMEDIATE
ATTENTION GIVEN TO THAT HORSE?
AND THAT NOT IN ALL CASES THAT
HORSE IS A EUTHANIZED THAT WE
REALLY TAKE A LOOK CAN THAT
HORSE BE SAVED.
CAN -- CAN SURGERY OCCUR AND CAN
THAT HORSE BE THEN -- INTRODUCED
INTO ANOTHER ENVIRONMENT WHERE
IT CAN LIVE -- UP UP THE REST OF
HIS LIFE.
AND THE OTHER.
PART THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE ARE ALSO.
I BELIEVE MAKING VERY GOOD IN
ROADS IS THE AFTER CARE PROGRAMS
AND I KNOW THAT OTHERS WILL BE
SPEAKING ABOUT KARMA -- TO
FOLLOW.
SINCE WE HAVE REOPENED SENT TO
NEEDED JUST TO PUT A LITTLE
CONTEXT AROUND THINGS.
WE'VE HAD ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND SESSIONS ON THE TRACK
SO HUNDRED THOUSAND HORSES
WHETHER BE RACING TRAINING OR
WORKING OUT.
WE'VE HAD TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
SINCE THE OPENING OF THE SEASON
SINCE THE TWENTY SIXTH OF
DECEMBER.
WE'VE HAD FIFTEEN HUNDRED HORSES
RACING WE'VE HAD OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND WORKOUTS WHICH MEANS
THOUSAND HORSES GALLOPING.
AND EVERY SINGLE DAY WE HAVE
ABOUT SEVENTEEN POINT SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED HORSES ON THE TRACK.
THOSE ARE VERY HIGH NUMBERS.
AS I SAID EARLIER AND CHAIRMAN
GRAY OPENED WITH THIS THAT.
CALIFORNIA RACING IS THE GOLD
STANDARD WE BELIEVE CALIFORNIA
RACING IS THE GOLD STANDARD.
HAVING MORE WORK I WOULD DO WELL
WE'VE COME QUITE AWAY WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S ALWAYS AN
ONGOING.
EXAMINATION THAT SHOULD OCCUR
CAM WE DO THINGS BETTER.
TOGETHER WORKING WITH OUR
INDUSTRY PARTNERS CAN WE MAKE
THINGS SAFER CAN WE FIND A
BETTER RACING SURFACE CAM WE
INSTITUTE BETTER PRO PROTOCOLS --
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT I'D LIKE
TO SEE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
CALIFORNIA RACING WE WANT TO SEE
CONSISTENCY ACROSS ALL OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THE STANDARDS ARE
CONSISTENT.
ALSO IMPORTANT IS THAT AS WE
HAVE THE GOLD STANDARD HEARING
CALIFORNIA IN NORTH AMERICA.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT THE
GOLD STANDARD MOVES ACROSS NORTH
AMERICA AND THAT THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY.
LOOKS AT THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE BECAUSE IF IT'S GOOD FOR
CALORIE CALIFORNIA RACING.
AND GOOD FOR THE HORSES HERE AND
THE WRITERS IN CALIFORNIA IT
SHOULD ALSO BE.
GOOD FOR HORSES ELSEWHERE IN THE
HEALTH AND WELFARE FORCES
ELSEWHERE.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SEE THAT THERE
IS GREATER TRANSPARENCY IN OUR
SPORT.
IN TERMS OF CONSISTENCY WITH
RESPECT TO REPORTING
CATASTROPHIC INJURY SO WE CAN
SEE.
WHO IS DOING IT RIGHT AND WHO
ISN'T DOING IT RIGHT?
AS WELL WITH RESPECT TO TRAINERS
WHEN THERE'S A TRAINER THAT HAS
AN INFRACTION IN ANOTHER STATE.
WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE TRANSPARENCY THERE.
AS WELL WE'VE I THINK MADE GREAT
WRECKED PROGRESS TOGETHER WITH
THE C. H. R. B..
WHERE VETERINARY RECORD SHOULD
FOLLOW THE HORSE AND SHOULD BE
TRANSPARENT FROM THAT TO THAT?
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT.
AS I HEARD SOME OF THE SPEAKERS
BEFORE -- WE WE COULD HAVE DONE
THIS WITHOUT THE SUPPORT OF
CHUCK WINNER AND THE ENTIRE
SEIZURE BE THEY MOVED VERY
QUICKLY.
BUT I ALSO HAVE TO COMMEND MY
INDUSTRY PARTNERS BECAUSE IT WAS
BECAUSE OF THE COLLABORATION
WITH THE SEAT.
THE C. D. T. WITH THE TOC.
WITH THE JOCKEYS WITH DEL MAR
WHERE THE INDUSTRYGOT TOGETHER
AND SAID WE REALLY HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING.
AND I THINK BECAUSE WE GOT
TOGETHER AND IT WAS INDUSTRY
LEAD WE WERE ALSO ABLE TO MOVE
VERY QUICKLY.
THROUGH THESE CHANGES AND THE CA
TURBIE ALSO RESPECTED THAT AND
WAS ON THE SAME PAGE AS WE WORK
AND AND I BELIEVE IT WAS THAT.
A COMBINATION OF CIRCUMSTANCES
AND EVENTS AND DESIRE TO MAKE
CHANGE AND PROGRESS IN REFORMS
THAT HAS BROUGHT US TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY.
SO -- ON THAT NOTE I WOULD LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO DR BENSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
DION BENSON I'M THE CHIEF
VETERINARY OFFICER FOR THE
STRONG A GROUP.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE TODAY --
IT'S SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
HAVE COME UP SURROUND THINGS
LIKE COURSE EXAMINATIONS AND ONE
OF THE JOBS THAT I'VE HAD UNTIL
THE THIRTY DAY THIS YEAR WAS I
WAS A VETERINARY.
A REGULATORY VETERINARIAN AT IN
KENTUCKY.
SO I'VE DONE THESE EXAMS.
AND SOME OF THE CHANGES THAT WE
HAVE MADE.
WILL HELP.
VETERINARIANS DO THESE JOBS
BETTER -- PLACED HER OUR BOOK
REFERENCING CHANGES REGARDING
CORTICOSTEROIDS AND NON%
STEROIDAL ANTI INFLAMMATORY.
THESE MEDICATIONS BY SEPARATING
THEM FROM BRACING ALLOW.
THE REGULATORY VETERINARIAN WHEN
THEY LOOK AT THAT HORSE AT EIGHT
IN THE MORNING.
THE DAY THAT IT RACES.
TO FEEL EVERYTHING THAT IS GOING
ON WITH THE HORSE TO HAVE MORE
INFORMATION HAVE BETTER ABILITY
TO DIAGNOSE THE HORSE -- FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO AREN'T AWARE
THOSE HORSES ARE LOOKED AT ONCE
IN THE MORNING THERE LOOKED AT
IN THE PADDOCK BY REGULATORY
VETERINARIAN THERE LOOKED AT IN
THE POST PARADE SO THAT FROM THE
MINUTE THEY LEAVE THE PADDOCK TO
GO TO THE GATE THEY WARM UP.
THEY ARE THERE OBSERVE BY A
REGULATORY VETERINARIAN -- IN
ALL OF THESE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
ENHANCED BY THE RULES THAT THE
STRONG A GROUP ENCOURAGED AND
MORE ADOPTED BY THE C. H. R. B. --
REGARDING CORTICOSTEROIDS AND
NON STEROIDAL ANTI
INFLAMMATORIES -- ALSO.
THE TRAINING REGULATIONS THAT WE
PUT IN PLACE ARE TRULY THE GOLD
STANDARD NOT JUST IN NORTH
AMERICA BUT IN THE WORLD.
THERE AREN'T THERE ISN'T ANOTHER
PLACE IN THE WORLD WHERE.
HORSES ARE REGULARLY OBSERVED
TESTED.
AND CHECKED BEFORE WORKING --
TRULY THAT IS A ONE OF A KIND
PROGRAM AND SOMETHING THAT WAS
PUT INTO EFFECT.
AFTER THIS RECENT EVENTS THESE
RECENT EVENTS -- YOU WITH
RESTRICTED MEDICATIONS AND POST
TRAINING TESTING PRE TRAINING
EXAMINATIONS AND A THOROUGH
REVIEW OF THE WORK HISTORY AND
AND RACING HISTORY IT REALLY
ALLOWS US TO GET A GOOD IDEA OF
WHETHER THESE HORSES ARE
APPROPRIATELY -- SET TO BE
TRAINED.
THE THE TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS
MENTIONED THE PT SCAN WE HOPE
WILL BE.
A GAME CHANGER FOR US THERE IS A
SPECIFIC BONE ON THE BACK OF THE
HORSES ANKLE.
THAT THERE IS A A DEFECT THAT
CANNOT BE IDENTIFIED BY ANY
EXISTING.
TECHNOLOGY AND THE P. E. T. SCAN
WHICH THIS TRYING TO GROUP --
DONATED HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ITS IT'S ACQUISITION.
WILL HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THOSE.
THOSE DEFICIENCIES ARE DEFECTS
AND TRULY THE ONE THING THAT I
AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
POSITION -- IS.
INNOVATION IS A BIG.
THING TO THIS COMPANY THEY
REALLY WANT TO FIND ANYTHING IF
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT WILL MAKE
HORSE RACING SAFER.
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN IT THEY
WANT TO LEARN ABOUT IT AND WE
REALLY WANT TO KNOW.
WHAT IF ANYTHING IS OUT THERE
THAT CAN MAKE HORSE RACING SAFE
THERE -- I DON'T I AM VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
COMING FROM A NON PROFIT WHERE
YOU'RE YOU'RE TRYING NOT TO
SPEND ANY MONEY IT'S REALLY
EXCITING TO HAVE A COMPANY THAT
IS REALLY ENTHUSED ABOUT THESE
TYPES OF OF ADVANCES REALLY
WILLING TO INVEST IN THE SPORT --
YEAH WE AREN'T -- WE ARE
CONSTRAINED BY.
ANY LIMITATIONS ON WHAT WILL
MAKE COURSE RACING SAFER IF
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT WE THINK
MAY MAKE HORSE RACING SAFER.
WHETHER IT BE LOOKING AT
TRAINING PRACTICES I KNOW
EARLIER SOMEONE MENTIONED THE
NUMBER OF HIGH SPEED FOR A LONG
AS OF COURSE DOES.
WE'RE LOOKING INTO THAT
INFORMATION IN TRYING TO SEE IF
THERE'S A WAY THAT AS IN
TRAINING WE CAN REGULATE THAT.
OR NOT TAKE ENTRIES OF A HORSE
HAS HAD TOO MANY HIGH SPEED FOR
A LONG FOR HIS TRAIN TOO MUCH
COMING UP TO A RACE OR WORK.
SO REALLY WE ARE LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO MAKE
HORSE RACING SAFER.
AND I HOPE YOU EVENTUALLY TO BE
THE THE GOLD STANDARD FOR THE
WORLD AND HAVE EVERYONE ASK WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S DOING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S MIKE ROGERS --
PRESIDENT STRONGER GROUP I'VE
BEEN AN EXECUTIVE WITH STRONG
RECOUP FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS I
SIT ON VARIOUS INDUSTRY BOARDS
FOR THE BREEDERS CUP TO THE
INJURY TO THE T. R. A..
WELCOME BASS I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS -- TO ADD I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND SUPPORT
THESE TWO FANTASTIC.
CENTER BRADFORD YES DOCTOR YOU
MENTIONED A BONE BEHIND THE%
ANKLE WAS THAT THE MOST COMMON
BREAKDOWN IN THE GINGER'S THAT
WE'VE SEEN THIS YEAR.
SO I DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
ACTUAL NAY CROSSES THAT HAPPENED
THIS YEAR AND CERTAINLY I'VE NOT
BEEN ON THE STRENGTH OF LONG
ENOUGH.
BUT FOR THE MAJORITY OF INJURIES
THAT OCCUR IN HORSES ARE CENTER
ON WHAT'S CALLED FAT LOCKER WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT OTHERS THEIR
INFO.
AND THIS IS CERTAINLY ONE PLACE
THAT WE CANNOT CURRENTLY
DIAGNOSE ANY ISSUES SO WE'RE
HOPING THAT THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY
WILL ALLOW US.
TO REMOVE THAT BLIND SPOT.
FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER GREAT.
CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND CERTAINLY.
I WILL COMMAND THE STRATA GROUP.
FOR GETTING OUT GRASS OF LEE --
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE RIGHT NOW I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF Là
DESIST REMAINS THE ON WHAT THE
SOLUTIONS MAY OR MAY NOT BE.
AND WHERE THE QUESTIONS A BITE
TO EAT ADDRESS TO THE
VETERINARIAN.
DR INTO THIS YOU KNOW.
SON THERE'S CRITICISM OUT THERE
THAT FOR EXAMPLE -- CHANGES TO
THE USEFUL -- AND MY SIX DON'T
MESS TO HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE BREAKDOWN.
HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND TO THAT
CRITICISM [inaudible]
SO.
LASIX MAY NOT HAVE ANYTHING TO
DO WITH BREAKDOWN SPECIFICALLY
FOR FRANKLY THE RESEARCH WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RESEARCH
WOULD BE I DON'T KNOW THAT
ANYONE IS EVER TAKEN A LONG TERM --
LOOK AT WHETHER THERE HAS BEEN
ANY CHANGE IN THE BREEDING OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT THAT HAS TO
DO WITH.
THE ABILITY TO USE LASIX SO
CERTAINLY THAT'S A QUESTION THAT
I CAN'T ANSWER BUT I DO KNOW
THAT BOTH OF THOSE ISSUES.
ARE SIGNIFICANT PERCEPTION
ISSUES FOR THE PUBLIC AND AT THE
END OF THE DAY IF PEOPLE DON'T
WANT TO COME TO RACING BECAUSE
THEY FEEL THAT.
COURSES ARE WHIPS OR THAT THEY
HAVE TO HAVE MEDICATION TO
COMPETE.
THEN WE DON'T HAVE A PRODUCT IN
WE NEED WE NEED TO BE DOING THE
BEST THING NOT ONLY FOR THE
HORSES BUT FOR THE SPORT.
I APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER AND SHE
TO BRING UP THE ISSUE OF
PERCEPTION BECAUSE I THINK THAT
DOES LIVE THROUGH AN OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE THE
STRONGER COOPER ANY OTHER -- YOU
KNOW INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDER CAN
IGNORE.
IT'S A SPORT THERE ARE FANS AND
YOU HAVE TO ENGAGE WITH THE
PUBLIC AND APPROPRIATE MANNER
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS.
BUT AS SOMEBODY WHO HAS A
EDUCATION ROOTED IN SCIENCE.
NOT ALL OF US HERE AT THE
LEGISLATURE ALWAYS.
DO A GOOD JOB OF ROUTING OUR
DECISIONS IN SCIENCE AND DATA.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY STRIKES ME AS
ODD WE LOOK IN -- WE ARE WE
LOOKING OTHER STATES AND WE ARE
WITH THESE CHANGES HAVE OCCURRED
IN YOU SEE -- FATALITIES DOWN
YOU LOOK EVEN YOU KNOW WE HAD
SOME DISCUSSION INTERNATIONAL
STANDARDS RIGHT AND CERTAINLY
AGAIN I APPLIED -- THE PURSUIT
OF THE HIGHEST STANDARDS IN ANY.
IN ANY CONCERTS -- BUT EVEN
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS THERE
ARE FATALITIES -- SO SOME OF THE
STRIKES ME AND I'LL CONTRACTORS
QUESTION OPEN AND LEADER WHOEVER
MIGHT WANT TO TAKE IT -- HOW DO
WE ADDRESS THE PUBLIC PERCEPTION
ISSUES THAT JUST FRANKLY DON'T
REALLY LINE UP WITH IT AND WE'RE
WE'RE YOU'LL FATALITIES ARE DOWN?
AND YET WE'RE HAVING A HEARING
HERE TODAY TO ADDRESS WHAT
PEOPLE EARLY SOME OF THE
PRESSURE OR OTHER PERCEPTION
FOLKS MY AND COHEN A CRISIS --
AND AGAIN IF IF THE RESULT OF
ALL THAT IS IS A CONTINUATION.
OF THE GOLD STANDARD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OR PERHAPS MAKING IT
THE PLATINUM STANDARD.
THEN -- THAT'S A GOOD THING TO
GET THE FOR THE INDUSTRY IT'S
GOOD TO BE A SUPPORT GROUP OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WITH THAT YOU KNOW HOW DO
YOU SEE THE PERCEPTION ISSUES
GOING FORWARD -- HELLO DOCTOR
BENSON TALK TO THE SCIENCE OF
THE I'LL TALK TO THE PERCEPTION.
SO -- AS I MENTIONED EARLIER OUR
OUR INDUSTRY IS ONE THAT IS IN
DECLINE.
SO WE HAVE A REAL CHALLENGE HOW
DO WE WANT TO GET THOSE NEW FANS
NEW GUESTS ARE INDUSTRY -- THAT
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT WE'RE LOOKING
TO ATTRACT -- DOES NOT WISH TO
SEE HORSES BEING DRUGGED.
OR RUNNING ON MEDICATION.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE HORSES
RUNNING ON PAGE OR TRAINING ON
PAIN MEDICATION.
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE
EXCESSIVE USE OF THE WEB FOR THE
CROP.
THOSE ARE THE VALUES THAT WE
ALSO EMBRACE IF IF WE DON'T
INCREASE THOSE VALUES.
THERE WILL BE A CONTINUATION A
CLIENT OF OUR BUSINESS -- IN OUR
INDUSTRY SO BUT THOSE ARE ALSO
VALUES THAT THAT WE DO EMBRACE
BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT OF COURSE
WELFARE -- AND WRITER WELFARE
THAT IS AT THE CENTER OF OF WHAT
WE DO [inaudible]
SO -- YOU KNOW WE JUST HAVE TO
DO THE RIGHT THING WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
IT WHAT WE DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
ALSO -- THAT WE ADVOCATE FOR
ADVOCATE FOR THE CHANGE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
THAT WE WE HAVE A UNIFORM
PLATFORM IN NORTH AMERICA.
I'M OFTEN ASKED WELL IF THEY CAN
RUN IN IN EUROPE WITHOUT LASIX
WHY CAN'T YOU.
IF THEY CAN RUN THE DUBAI WORLD
CUP.
WITHOUT LASIX WHY CAN'T YOU.
SO IT.
PERHAPS SOME OF ITS PERCEPTION
ISSUE.
PERHAPS -- THE SCIENCE YOU KNOW
THERE IS MIXED -- DEBATE AROUND
THE SCIENCE DOES IT CONTRIBUTE.
TO CATASTROPHIC INJURY INJURIES
OR DOES IT CONTRIBUTE TO A A
WEAKENING OF THE THOROUGHBRED --
FREE -- THAT -- YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S A QUESTION FOR SCIENCE
BUT FROM A PERCEPTION STANDPOINT
FROM THE NEW GUESTS THAT WE WISH
TO ATTRACT.
WE HAVE TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
THOSE VALUES [inaudible] SEVEN
REVIEW.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN I JUST HAVE A
A FOLLOW UP -- TO WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GREGIS AUS OUT THE
PERCEPTION PIECE IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT YOU ARE DOING TO
BE PROACTIVE IN TERMS OF
MESSAGING BECAUSE CLEAR YES HE
WAS STATING -- YOU KNOW THE
MEDIAN WE'VE ALL HEARD AT THAT
THEY'RE NOT DOING JUST AS IN
TERMS OF OF ALL THE EFFORT SAY
YOU'RE TRYING TO PUT.
THAT FORWARD TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER IS THERE ANY PLAN IS
THERE.
SOME KIND OF OUTREACH THAT YOU
PLANTED TO IN TERMS OF CHANGING
PERCEPTION.
WELL I THINK THE YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY THE ACTIONS WE TAKE
THE REAL ACTIONS THAT THE
REFORMS THE CHANGE.
WILL HELP TO CHANGE PERCEPTIONS
THIS ISN'T A PR STUNT WE'RE NOT
DOING THIS FOR FOR GOOD PR WE'RE
TRYING TO REALLY IDENTIFY WHAT
ARE THOSE MEETING FULL CONCRETE
REFORMS THAT WE COULDN'T PLAY
PUT CAN PUT IN PLACE.
THE TRULY AFFECT THE OUTCOME --
AT THE END OF THE DAY AND THEN.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON ALL OF US IN THE INDUSTRY
TO ADVOCATE THE POSITIVES THAT
OUR INDUSTRY -- AND OUR SPORT
DOES BRING.
AND WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW --
JOBS THE LOVE OF HORSES THE
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES THAT WORK IN
OUR INDUSTRY.
AND THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE ARE
MAKING CONCRETE IMPROVEMENTS
WITH RESPECT TO HORSE WELFARE
AND WRITER WELFARE.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS WE HAVE TO
COLLECTIVELY KEEP.
KEEP -- KEEP TALKING ABOUT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE NOT
TAKING IT AS A PUPPY SPLIT THIS
EAST ON BECAUSE CLEARLY -- SOME
HORSES HALF HAVE DIED BUT IN THE
REASON I SAY THAT BECAUSE IT IS
MY DISTRICT.
NAKED CALLS ALL THE TIME ABOUT
THE NUMBERS OF COURSE IS THAT
DIED IN IT'S NOT ACCURATE I
DON'T KNOW HOW. TO ACCURATELY
DEFENDED -- AND I'M NOT TRYING
TO I'M TRYING TO JUST MAKE SURE
TO BE HONEST YOU KNOW BUT MY
POINT IS THAT.
THE MESSAGE KEEPS GETTING BIGGER
AND BIGGER BY THAI PEOPLE HEAR
IT AND AND I KNOW IT'S JUST A
SUGGESTION BECAUSE YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S INFORMATION TO BE
CLARIFIED.
IT IS WOULD BE HELPFUL SO PEOPLE
DON'T BLOW THINGS OUT OF
PROPORTION SO BUT YOU KNOW IT'S
JUST A LITTLE WORK TO DO.
THANK YOU -- BUT YOU SAW THE
FINAL QUESTION YOU KNOW.
OR I'LL START WITH THE STATE AND
THEN JUST HAVE YOU COMMENT ON IT
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE INDUSTRY
HAS TO HAVE BETTER METRICS.
I MEAN WE'VE HAD THIS SAY
THERE'S TWENTY SIXTH.
TWENTY FIVE YES THIS YEAR BUT
THEN WE HEAR.
ABOUT HOW WAR AT THE LOWEST
POINT THAT WE'VE BEEN A LONG
TIME IN THE INDUSTRY AND YOU
KNOW THOSE. TWO IMPORTANT --
DATA SETS ARE CONFLICTING IT'S
SO WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE -- THAT
ARE -- YOU KNOW AND NOT AS UP ON
IT AS YOU ALL ARE -- THEN YOU
GET THESE PERCEPTIONS.
IS SO PERCEPTIONS ASIDE WE STILL
AT TWENTY FIVE ANIMALS DIED THIS
YEAR.
AND I THINK THE INDUSTRY SHOULD
COME UP WITH.
SOME METRICS SO THAT -- NOT THAT
THERE -- IT'S NOT LIKE PUTTING
LIPSTICK ON A PIG IF YOU WILL
IT'S REALLY HARD CORE THESE ARE
HOW MANY RUNS A WE HAVE THIS.
IT IN IN MAYBE CITING SOME
STATISTICS -- YOU OFFER A LOT
FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME OR
YOU KNOW SOME POINT IN TIME THIS
JUST MAY BE -- AN ABERRATION I
DON'T KNOW CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THAT. FIFTY CREATURE SURE --
THERE IS A A DATABASE THAT RACE
TRACKS ARE INVITED TO USE IN
THAT ALL OF THE STRONG A GROUP
TRACKS TO USE IT'S CALLED THE
EQUINE ENTRY DATABASE THAT
TRACKS THE NUMBER OF INJURIES.
OVER TIME FOR HORSES AND WHEN I
STARTED IN THIS INDUSTRY SEVEN
EIGHT YEARS AGO.
TOO WEIRD TWO PER THOUSAND
CATASTROPHIC INJURIES -- PER
THOUSAND INSTANCES OF RACING.
WE ARE NOW DOWN AS AN INDUSTRY
ABOUT ONE POINT.
EIGHT L..
THAT IS CERTAINLY A GREAT
IMPROVEMENT AND BUT I DON'T
THINK ANYONE FEELS THAT WERE
DONE AND YOU KNOW YOU LOOK AT
OTHER COUNTRIES AND THERE ARE
SOME THAT ARE ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER -- I DON'T THINK WE EVEN
NEED TO SHOOT FOR WHAT OTHER
COUNTRIES DO I THINK OUR GOAL IS --
ZERO PER THOUSAND WE MAY NEVER
GET THERE BUT I THINK WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS THAT --
YOU KNOW AND AND THAT IS
ULTIMATELY THE GOAL.
I ALSO THINK THAT IF YOU -- LOOK
AT THE NUMBERS.
SINCE.
THE REFORMS HAVE BEEN UNDERTAKEN.
WERE AT 2% IN THOUSAND OR TWO
PER EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED ACTUALLY
WHEN YOU INCLUDE RACING SO
THAT'S CERTAINLY AN IMPROVEMENT
FROM WHERE WE HAVE BEEN AND WE
CONTINUE. TO HOPE THAT TREND
CONTINUES.
BUT WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOWARDS ZERO NO MATTER WHAT
WE'RE DOING WHAT NUMBER WERE AT
AT THE TIME.
LET'S IN LESS SOMEBODY HAS
SOMETHING ELSE LET'S AND ON THAT
NOTE I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU
COMING HERE TODAY AND AND GIVING
US YOUR VALUABLE.
WHAT'S GOING ON AND YET.
WITH STROLLER GROUP IN
PARTICULAR THANK YOU.
NOW THE NATIONAL PERSPECTIVE
WHAT ALEX WALDRON PRESIDENT CEO.
NATIONAL THOROUGHBRED RACING
ASSOCIATION.
IT CHAIR RACING -- MEDICATION
AND TESTING CONSORTIUM AND CRAIG --
SORRY CAN'T READ HERE.
BROUGH -- PRESIDENT CEO OF THE
BREEDERS CUP LIMITED.
WELCOME [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CREATE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU.
ALSO WANT TO COMMEND THESE
COMMITTEES FOR YOUR INTEREST IN
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC OF HORSE
RACING SAFETY -- IS A CONCERN
WHICH IS UNDOUBTEDLY FUNDAMENTAL
TO THE FUTURE OF COURSE RACING
NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I AM ALEX WALDER PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE NATIONAL THOROUGHBRED
RACING ASSOCIATION AND ALSO
CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
OF THE RACING MEDICATION AND
TESTING CONSORTIUM -- WHAT WE
CALL THE RTC?
I'M BEFORE YOU TODAY
REPRESENTING TWO NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE AT THE
HEART OF THE U. S. RACING
INDUSTRIES EXTENSIVE.
AND ONGOING EFFORTS TO ENHANCE
THE SAFETY AND WELFARE OF HORSE
RACING'S EC WINE AND HUMAN
ATHLETES.
I'LL BEGIN BY DISCUSSING THE RTC.
THE RTC CONSIST OF TWENTY THREE
RACING INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDER
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT REPRESENT MULTIPLE READS OF
RACING -- FOR MOST FOR MORE THAN
TWO DAYS TO TECH FOR ALMOST TWO
DECADES OF THE R. M. T. C. HAS
ENSURE THE SAFETY AND WELFARE OF
RESOURCES.
BY DEVELOPING AND PROMOTING
SCIENCE BASED UNIFORMITY CATION
REGULATIONS.
ESTABLISHING CONSISTENT HIGH
QUALITY DRUGS TESTING STANDARDS.
COORDINATING AND FUNDING ILLICIT
SUBSTANCE RESEARCH.
AND GENERATING EDUCATIONAL
INITIATIVES THAT ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF RACE.
AND PARTICIPANTS.
CALIFORNIA STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE C. H. R. B. ARE
AMONG THE MOST ACTIVE
PARTICIPANTS AND FUNDERS OF THE
RTC.
OOPS ON MORE.
THE RTC PROVIDES CRITICAL
SUPPORT TO REGULATORY
AUTHORITIES ACROSS THE US
INCLUDING THE C. H. ARMY.
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF WHAT
WE CALL OUR NATIONAL UNIFORMITY
CATION PROGRAM -- THIS ARE ANTI
SAID THE CEDAR FELT MEDICATION
REFORM INITIATIVE IS NOW PART OF
THE NATIONAL MODEL RULES OF
RACING.
ADOPTED BY THE ASSOCIATION OF
RACING COMMISSIONERS
INTERNATIONAL ARE WE WE CALL THE
R. C. I APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE FOR
ALL THE ACRONYMS -- THE NATIONAL
UNIFORMITY CATION PROGRAM
CREATES A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
AND PROVIDE UNIFORMLY GALATIANS
ACROSS ALL COMPLIANCE STATES --
THIS PROGRAM INCLUDES A LIST OF
PERMITTED THERAPEUTIC
MEDICATIONS INCLUDING TESTING%
LIMITS AND RECOMMENDED
MEDICATION WITHDRAWAL TIMES
KNOWN AS THE CONTROLLED
THERAPEUTIC.
SUBSTANCES LIST.
THE PROGRAM ALSO INCLUDES
RIGOROUS CONTROLS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF FUROSEMIDE
ALSO KNOWN AS LASIX.
THEREBY REMOVING PRIVATE
VETERINARY ACCESS TO OUR HORSES
ON RACE DAY.
THE PROGRAM INCLUDES A NATIONAL
MULTIPLE MEDICATION VIOLATION
PENALTY SYSTEM TO ENHANCE PUBLIC
PALACE MEANT FOR HORSE TRAINERS
WITH INCREASING MEDICATION ABOUT
LIKE VIOLATIONS REGARDLESS OF
THE STATE IN WHICH THE OFFENSE
OCCURRED.
THE FOURTH COMPONENT OF THE
NATIONAL PROGRAM IS THE ARM TC'S
LABORATORY ACCREDITATION AND
EXTERNAL QUALITY ASSURANCE
PROGRAM.
THE RTC ACCREDITS LABORATORIES
THAT DEMONSTRATE CONSISTENT AND
RELIABLE DETECTION FOR A WIDE
VARIETY OF SUBSTANCES AT LOW
CONCENTRATIONS -- THE NINE OR
MTC ACCREDITED LABORATORIES
WHICH INCLUDE THE UC DAVIS MADDY
LAM.
NOW PROVIDE TESTING FOR OF
SAMPLES FOR THIRTY TWO OF THIRTY
FOUR PARA MUTUAL RACING
JURISDICTIONS.
RECENTLY THE AREN'T YOU SEE ALSO
DEVELOPED AN EXPANSIVE OUT OF
COMPETITION TESTING PROGRAM
WHICH INCLUDES.
A CORRESPONDING PROHIBITED
SUBSTANCES LIST.
THIS OUT OF COMPETITION TESTING
PROGRAM IS AS COMPREHENSIVE AS
ANY IN THE WORLD AND HAS BEEN
FULLY AND AGGRESSIVELY
IMPLEMENTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
BY THE C. H. R. B..
CALIFORNIA HAS FULLY ADOPTED THE
NATIONAL UNIFORM PROGRAM.
WITH THE EXCEPTION.
OF THE MEDICAL MULTIPLE
MEDICATION VALID VIOLATION
PENALTY SYSTEM.
WHICH IS UNDER REVIEW BY YOU THE
LEGISLATIVE TEAM -- FOR THE C.
H. R. B..
CURRENTLY -- THE RTC.
IMPROVES DETECTION OF ILLICIT OR
PROHIBITED SUBSTANCES THROUGH
OUR TACTICAL RESEARCH PROGRAM --
THE RAPID TEST DEVELOPMENT
PROVIDED BY THE THE TACTICAL
RESEARCH PROGRAM IS CRUCIAL TO A
RADIC HEADING PERSISTENT
CHEATERS.
IDENTIFYING UNKNOWN SUBSTANCES
FOR REGULATORY AUTHORITIES AND
REGULATED RACETRACK OPERATORS.
AND COLLABORATING WITH
LABORATORIES TO TACKLE BLOOD
DOPING IN AN HOUR ANABOLIC
AGENTS -- THAT ARE PROVEN
ESSENTIAL TO THE COMPANY
REGULATION OF THE SPORT.
THE LIST OF OUR MTC
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE
RESULTED IN NEW YORK A. R. C. I.
MODEL RULES JUST IN THE FIGHT
LAST FIVE YEARS IS TO LINK THE
YOU CAN SEE AN COMPLICATED TO
MENTION.
BUT THE WORK GOES ON AND I WILL
NOTE THE CALIFORNIA HAS ADOPTED
OR IS IN THE PROCESS OF ADOPTING
ALL OF OUR R. M. T. C.
RECOMMENDED NATIONAL MODEL RULES.
THE LIST THE LIST OF CALIFORNIA
TRACKS AND ASSOCIATIONS THAT
SUPPORT AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
ARE IN DC IS LINKING.
AND GIVEN THE COMMITMENT.
OF THE RTC TO A SAFER RACING
ENVIRONMENT -- THE RTC WILL
STRONGLY CONSIDER RECOMMENDING
CALIFORNIA'S ENHANCED
CORTICOSTEROID IN ANTI
INFLAMMATORY POLICIES. TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE NATIONAL
UNIFORMITY CATION PROGRAM AND
PERHAPS AS MODEL RULES.
SO NEXT NOW FOCUS MY EFFORTS ON
THE N. T. R. A. AND ITS SAFETY
AND INTEGRITY ON ITS.
AS PART OF OUR MISSION TO PURSUE
CONSENSUS DRIVEN SOLUTIONS TO
INDUSTRY PROBLEMS.
THE INTERIOR CREE THE INTERIOR A
SAFETY IN INTEGRITY ALLIANCE
WHOSE FUNCTION IT IS TO
IMPLEMENT.
NUMEROUS PROVED PROVEN SAFETY
INITIATIVES ON A NATIONWIDE
BASIS INCLUDING THE NATIONAL
UNIFORM MEDICATION PROGRAM.
THE FUNDAMENTAL FUNDAMENTAL TO
THE ALLIANCE IS THE CONVICTION
THAT.
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
HUMAN AND NECKLINE ATHLETES IN
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR SPORT OUR
HORSE RACING'S TOP PRIORITIES.
WE FORMED THE ALLIANCE AS A
CATALYST FOR CHANGE AFTER A BILL
SUFFERED CATASTROPHIC INJURIES
AND WAS EUTHANIZED ON TRACK
AFTER THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
KENTUCKY DERBY.
AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TRIPLE
CROWN THE END TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
OF GRAND HOPEFUL BIG BROWN.
WAS REVEALED TO BE LEGALLY
RECEIVING REGULAR CYCLES OF
ANABOLIC STEROIDS.
SUDDENLY HORSE RACING FOUND
ITSELF ON THE FRONT PAGE OF
NATIONAL NEWSPAPERS AND FOR ALL
THE WRONG REASONS.
IN ADDITION CONGRESS WAS ASKING
TOUGH QUESTIONS THERE INDUSTRY
WAS HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME
ANSWERING.
RACING UNDERSTOOD THEN AS IT
DOES NOW THAT A LOT CAN BE LOST
IF WE FAIL TO ASSURE THE SAFETY
OF OUR HORSES AND RIDERS.
AND THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
COMPETITION.
SO BY THE END OF TWO THOUSAND
NINE THE SAFETY IN INTEGRITY
ALLIANCE.
ALONG WITH A HOST OF OTHER
INDUSTRY.
INITIATIVES WAS IN FULL GEAR
DEMONSTRATING THAT BY WORKING
TOGETHER.
GOVERNMENT AND INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS CAN REFORM THE
INDUSTRY.
THE ALLIANCE'S PURPOSES PURPOSE
IS TO ESTABLISH AN SECURE
IMPLEMENTATION OF NATIONAL
STANDARDS TO PROMOTE SAFETY IN
INTEGRITY.
THROUGH AN IT HERE IT'S TO IT
ALLIANCE CODE OF STANDARDS --
THE ALLIANCE IMPLEMENTS AND
ENFORCES THESE STANDARDS
EMBODIED IN THE CODE TO A
COMPREHENSIVE ACCREDITATION
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM. TO BE CREDITED A
RACETRACK MUST DEMONSTRATE IN
WRITING AND BY PASSING A
RIGOROUS ONSITE INSPECTION.
IT HAS IT HAS SUBSTANTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED ALL REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE ALLIANCE GO TO STANDARDS.
AND THOSE THAT CODE COVER SIX
BROAD AREAS.
INTO REPORTING AND PREVENTION.
A SAFER RACING AND TRAINING AND
WALDRON WE WE CAN READ THAT OKAY
JUST YOU CAN SEE THAT.
SO COLLEGE EYES SO TIME DOESN'T
PERMIT ME TO GO INTO A DEEPER
PRESENTATION OF THE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE PAGE BECAUSE
STANDARDS.
YES.
SO I CAN JUST POINT YOU TO W. W.
W. THAT INTERIOR ALLIANCE DOT
COM -- I WILL SAY THAT THE CO
STANDARDS IS AN EVOLVING
DOCUMENT ITS UPDATED
CONTINUOUSLY AND MODIFIED BASED
UPON THESE FOR STANDARDS
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE PUBLIC
SUBMISSIONS.
OBSERVE BEST PRACTICES AND THE
MODEL RULES AS THEY CHANGE -- WE
HAVE AN ADVISORY BOARD -- THAT'S
CONSISTING OF MANY OF OUR
INDUSTRIES KEY STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS THAT REVIEW AND REVISE
THE CODE OF STANDARDS AT LEAST
ONCE ANNUALLY.
BY UPDATING THE CODE CONST
CONSTANTLY AND BY HEARING TO A
BIENNIAL RE ACCREDITATION CYCLE
WE MAKE SURE THAT PARTICIPATING
TRACKS.
ARE CONSTANTLY AND CONTINUOUSLY
IMPROVING.
RIGHT NOW THERE TWENTY FOUR
CREDITED RACETRACKS ACQUIRE
ACCOUNTING 490% A GRADED STAKES.
96%.
OF STAKES RACES IN 75% OF NORTH
AMERICAN WAGERING.
HERE ON CALIFORNIA'S ACCREDITED
TRACKS AND IT NEEDED DEL MAR
GOLDEN GATE FIELDS.
AND ALSO METERS.
AND YOU CAN SHARE IT READY SURE
REST ASSURE THAT THE ALLIANCE IS
ALREADY AT WORK ANALYZING THE
CHANGES RECENTLY EMIT
IMPLEMENTED BY THE STRONG TO
GROUPS CALIFORNIA TRACKS.
AND SOON TO BE ADOPTED BY DEL
MAR.
THESE CHANGES THE TERM -- IF
THEY'RE DETERMINED TO BE
BENEFICIAL TO THE SAFETY AND
WELFARE OF THE HORSE THEY WILL
EVENTUALLY BECOME PART OF OUR
CODE OF STANDARDS -- REFORMS
IMPLEMENTED BY THE SAFE
MATERIALIZE THE ARE IN DC AND
OTHER LIKE MINDED ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE C. H. R. B. HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO A 16% DECLINE IN
EC ONE FATALITIES.
NATIONALLY THAT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE LIKEWISE EVEN
WITH THE RECENT SPATE OF
FATALITIES AT SENATE NIDA
CALIFORNIA IS ON TRACK TO RECORD
ITS SECOND THE SECOND FUSE
FATALITIES.
SUCH BECAME CHANGE BEGIN
RECORDING THOSE IN -- NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE THE PROGRESS BOTH
NATIONALLY AND IN CALIFORNIA IS
UNDENIABLE.
BUT WE CAN AND WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING EVEN MORE TO PROTECT
THE HORSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANKS MISS
WALDRON VERY IMPRESSIVE -- THE
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CRAIG FOR EVIL AND THE
CHAIRMAN OF AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT CEO THE BREEDERS CUP.
FORMALLY PRESIDENT GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE DEL MAR
THOROUGHBRED CLUB -- AND SO I GO
BACK A LONG WAY IN CALIFORNIA
RACING I'M.
HERE TO DEMONSTRATE TO YOU THAT
THE LACK OF PREPARED COMMENTS IS
A GREAT ASSISTANCE AND BREVITY
SO.
I WILL -- WITHHOLD ANY FORMAL
COMMENTS AND SIMPLY STATE -- HOW
IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA RACING IS
AND I'M HERE PRIMARILY TODAY --
AS ERIC REQUESTED ME TO DO TO TO
TESTIFY.
THE IMPORTANCE OF CALIFORNIA
RACING TO THE NATIONAL RACING
ENVIRONMENT.
AND AS A A GREAT THE HOST SITE
FOR THE BREEDERS CUP -- WE HAVE
HELD THE BREEDERS CUP NINE TIMES
AT SENATOR WERE SCHEDULED TO
HOLD THE BREEDERS CUP AGAIN
THERE -- IN EARLY NOVEMBER THE
FIRST WEEKEND IN NOVEMBER -- TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE HELD THE
BREEDERS CUP AT DEL MAR FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ROUTINELY
AMONGST OUR MOST SUCCESSFUL
HIGHLY -- ANTICIPATED AND
ENJOYABLE BREEDERS CUPS --
PARTLY THANKS TO THE GREAT
MANAGEMENT TEAMS AND HORSEMEN --
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO TO
THE STUPENDOUS WHETHER BOTH IN
ARCADIA -- AND AND DEL MAR --
AYE IN ADDITION TELL YOU HOW
IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA IS TO US
NOT JUST OF THE BREEDERS CUP
INTO THE BREEDING INDUSTRY -- IT
IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO TELL YOU
WHAT A GREAT EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA
SAID OVER THE YEARS AND I AS I
SAID I STARTED WORKING IN THE
RACING INDUSTRY IN.
NINETEEN NINETY MY FIRST JOB WAS
AT DEL MAR WHICH I'D LOVE TO
TAKE THE BREEDERS CUP IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN OVER THAT TIME
SPAN.
I WAS ABLE TO OBSERVE HOW MANY
NEW INITIATIVES WERE BEGUN HERE
IN CALIFORNIA FROM THE FIRST
EQUINE MEDICAL DIRECTOR THAT
SENATOR.
MADDY CONJURED UP -- IN A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. TO THE NECROPSY
PROGRAM TO THE MADDIE LABORATORY
AT UC DAVIS. TO SAFETY RAILS
BEING THE FIRST ASSAULT AROUND
THE COUNTRY I COULD GO ON AND ON
BUT CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN
FIRST.
AND ONCE AGAIN UNFORTUNATELY OUR
FIRST ON THE BED OF A POINT OF
THE SPEAR HERE BECAUSE OF THAT A
RECENT UNFORTUNATE SERIES OF
EVENTS BUT YOU'VE ALSO.
SHOWN A GREAT EXAMPLE FOR HOW TO
REACT TO THAT KIND OF SITUATION
HOW TO IMPLEMENT REFORMS DOES
NOT RELAX.
TO INSTITUTIONALIZE THE
VIGILANCE WE ALL NEED TO BE MORE
AND MORE CAREFUL ABOUT AND I
THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK TO
BE DONE -- PEOPLE SAY WHAT CAN
WE DO I THINK NATIONALLY A LOT
OF THE REFORMS THAT ARE BEING
DISCUSSED HERE.
NEED TO BE INSTITUTIONALIZED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE NEED TO
FIND WAYS TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
MORE EFFECTIVELY MOREQUICKLY --
AND AND MORE UNIVERSALLY SO THAT
CALIFORNIA'S AND SITTING ON AN
ISLAND BY ITSELF SO -- I COMMEND
YOU FOR YOUR WORK -- THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD
HAS BEEN A GREAT PARTNER TO THE
BREEDERS CUP WE HAVE DONE.
ALL KINDS OF NEW INITIATIVES
WITH THEM FROM -- ERADICATING
LASIX FROM TWO YEAR OLD RACES IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND THIRTEEN
DURING THE BREEDERS CUP -- TO
OTHER FORMS OF OUT OF
COMPETITION TESTING THAT BEEN
DONE IN CONJUNCTION WITH DR
ARTHUR IN THE MEDICAL TEAM --
AND MANY MANY MORE -- THAT HAVE
SET GREAT EXAMPLES FOR SAFETY
AND INTEGRITY AROUND THE
INDUSTRY AND WE'RE PROUD TO BE A
PART OF IT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
I'VE GOT -- ONE I I I MENTIONED
THIS EARLIER AND I JUST WANT TO
GET YOUR PERSPECTIVE PERHAPS --
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE STATS
HERE CALIFORNIA COMPARED -- TO
YOU OVERSEAS IN TERMS OF COURSE
YEAH DOUBTS IN AGAIN.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT ANY
SPECIFIC METRICS EXCEPT.
FOR YEAH WHAT'S HAPPENED THIS
YEAR SO FAR CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THAT ANY THOUGHT YOU HAVE ON
THAT [inaudible]
WELL THE I THINK IT'S ALWAYS
IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE SURE
WE'RE COMPARING APPLES TO APPLES --
AND THAT'S AND I THINK THAT'S
THE FIRST QUESTION WHEN WHEN WE
SAY.
BUT WE DO ABOUT THE U. S. VERSUS --
OF EUROPEAN OR INTERNATIONAL
STANDARDS -- WE WE IN THIS
COUNTRY I HAVE A ONE METRIC I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH WHAT HAPPENS --
IN EUROPE -- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT MEMBER THEY RAISE
PRIMARILY ON ON GRASS -- AND
SYNTHETIC WHERE AS WE RACE ON
DIRT THAT'S A DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE ENTIRELY -- THOSE
THINGS AFFECT THOSE NUMBERS AS
WELL -- BUT ANYWAY YOU SLICE IT
THE THE US NEEDS TO IMPROVE ON
OUR A FATALITY RATE --
NATIONWIDE AND AND IT LETTER
EVERY LEVEL -- WE NEED TO BE
BELOW EUROPE -- WERE EVERY TIAS --
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND AMERICAN
PUBLIC WANTS THAT -- THAT'S NOT
ONLY TRUE IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
THAT'S TRUE ACROSS THE COUNTRY --
AND SO WE WANTED TO MEET AND
EXCEED YOUR AND AND IT'S IT'S
IT'S STANDARD -- THINK IT'S
SOMETHING TO SHOOT FOR BUT WE'VE
MADE PROGRESS AND I'M PROUD TO
SAY WE MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND
AND WITH THESE NEW REFORMS.
THAT HAVE COME ALONG IN
CALIFORNIA MAYBE WE CAN MAKE
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS WELL AND I'M EXCITED
TO DIG INTO. TO THE THE THINGS
YOU'VE DONE HERE ALL THE THINGS
YOU'VE DONE HERE TO SEE WHAT WE
CAN.
IMPLEMENT ACROSS THE COUNTRY --
TO TO BRING FATALITIES DOWN IN
OTHER IN OTHER STATES.
AND YOU MAY HAVE ANSWERED AS
APOLOGIZE IF I MISSED YOU YOU
MENTIONED.
THE UNITED STATES VERSUS
EUROPEAN AND OTHER.
FOREIGNERS BUT WHAT ABOUT WITHIN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT SOME
STATES.
ARE ALLOWING US YOU KNOW.
SOME THINGS THAT OTHER STATES
DON'T DESERVE.
WHAT'S THE UNIFORMITY LOOK LIKE
AMONG THE STATES IN IN AMERICA.
WELL -- IT COULD BE BETTER -- WE
HAVE WE HAVE THE THE MID
ATLANTIC THE THERE ARE I THINK
ELEVEN STATES FROM NEW YORK --
DOWN THROUGH VIRGINIA THAT WORK
TOGETHER AND THEY'RE VERY CLOSE
IN IN PROXIMITY SO THEY HAVE A
GREAT DEAL OF UNIFORMITY IN IN
THAT AREA -- BEYOND THAT THERE
AND THERE'S NO ONE REGION -- THE
NATIONAL UNIFORMITY CATION
PROGRAM.
HAS SUBSTANTIAL UNIFORMITY BUT
IT NEEDS TO BE ADOPTED IN
CERTAIN MAJOR STATES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA WE SAID TO MAKE TO
HAVE PERFECT.
UNIFORMITY SO THERE'S WORK TO BE
DONE THERE IS NO QUESTION WE
NEED TO ACT FASTER AND WE NEED
TO GET THAT DONE THE HORSES ARE
TRAVELING AROUND THE COUNTRY
THEY'RE GOING TO ALL THESE
DIFFERENT REGIONS TO RACE IS
THAT CORRECT THAT'S TRUE.
SO IS THERE A NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION THAT'S LOOKING AT
THESE ISSUES TO TRY TO GET IT
UNIFORM WELL THAT'S WHAT THE RTC
IS ABOUT THAT'S WHAT THE
ALLIANCE DO TOGETHER THEY WORK
HAND IN GLOVE. TO ESTABLISH THE
UNIFORM PROGRAM AND TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROGRAM AND AND THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THOSE TWO
ORGANIZATIONS ARE FOCUSED ON NOT
EXCLUSIVELY BUT THAT'S A BIG
PART OF WHAT THEY DO -- AND SO
IT'S UP TO TO US IF YOU WILL TO
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND THEN YOU
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER THAT
THERE'S A UNITED STATES IS
MOSTLY DIRT EUROPE IS MOSTLY.
GRASS AND ARTIFICIAL TURF IS OUR
ARTIFICIAL.
YEAH THERE ARE ARTIFICIAL
SERVICES OR WE HAVE SOME OF
THOSE WHO REJECT -- THE SOULS
WITH AMONGST THE DIFFERENT
REGIONS IN THE UNITED STATES IS
THERE ARE DIFFERENT ARE THE THE
IS THERE A DIFFERENCE IN THE
DIRT OR IS IT PRETTY MUCH THE
SAME AS WELL I'M GONNA I'M GONNA
DEFERRED TO SERVER THE OTHER
SERVICES AS GENERALLY ON THE HOW
pUNIFORMITY.
WELL I THINK I THINK I'M GOING
TO DEFER TO DOCTOR PETERSON
WHO'S GOING TO BE UP NEXT HE
WILL TELL YOU THAT SERVICES AND
AND HE WILL I THINK IS THE OF
THE THE RESIDENT EXPERT AND HE
KNOWS A LOT ABOUT HOW.
A GOOD DIRT TRACK COULD BE AS
SAFE AS A AS A SYNTHETIC TRACK
BUT SO HE'LL HE'LL EXPLAIN THAT
LATER BUT THAT'S AN AREA WHERE
WE NEED TO IMPROVE -- I IT'S GOT
TO BE REALLY QUICK BECAUSE I
WANT TO GET THE NEXT ONE UP CAN
YOU EXPLAIN THE PROCESS THE
BREEDERS CUP IS IMPLEMENTED FOR
TRAINERS.
WHO'VE BEEN SANCTIONED FOR
MEDICAL VIOLATION OF A SPECIFIC
CATEGORY BY RACING.
REGULATORY AGENCY OVER ONE YEAR
DURATION.
AND IT HAS NOT BEEN EFFECTIVE I
THINK I THINK YOU JUST DESCRIBED
A IF IF TRAINERS HAVE.
CERTAIN TYPES OF OF CLASS -- ONE
VIOLATIONS I BELIEVE CLASS -- TO
WITHOUT SOME PARTICULAR PERIOD
OF TIME PRIOR TO THE BREEDERS
CUP -- THEY'RE PRECLUDED FROM
ENTERING SO WE WE WE MAINTAIN
COMPLETE DISCRETION OVER THE
ENTRY FORCES IN THE BREEDERS CUP
ENOUGH.
F. TRAINERS OR OWNERS ARE OTHERS
DON'T MEET THE STANDARDS THEN WE
JUST DON'T LET THEM RACE AMERICA.
THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
AND FOR EVERYBODY YOU KNOW I
KNOW THIS TIME THE TIMING IS --
IT IS WORTH NOTING THOUGH DO WE
WERE AN HOUR LATE BECAUSE THE
ASSEMBLY WAS STILL GOING.
IN WE HAVE A SENATOR LEFT.
SO -- NEXT PANEL.
IN THIS OF THE STAFF.
ASSEMBLY STAFF DEDICATED LOYAL
[inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL
PETERSON MAKE I GO BY -- THINK
HAD SLIDES UP HERE I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU GET TO HIM [inaudible]
OF ALL RIGHT.
UP.
SO -- I AM A I AM DIRECTOR BAGGY
QUINN PROGRAMS THAT --
UNIVERSITY OF KENTUCKY AND I AM
OF PROFESSOR AND BY ASSISTANCE
AGRICULTURAL ENGINEERING -- MY
EXPERTISE TO SEE AN OF RACING
SURFACES.
OF WHAT I'M HERE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT TODAY IS THE EFFORTS
THEY'VE BEEN MADE TO IMPROVE
RACING SERVICES -- ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND CALIFORNIA'S BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THESE EFFORTS.
OF WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT WE
REFER TO THE MAINTENANCE QUALITY
SYSTEM THAT'S IMPLEMENTED A
DOZEN OF THE TOP TRACKS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
OF THOSE THAT INCLUDES DEL MAR
AND SANTA ANITA.
IT'S A THREE PHASE PROCESS THAT
WE USE WERE.
SAMPLES ARE TAKEN FROM THE
RACETRACK SURFACE AND ARE
UTILIZED AND ARE TESTED AT OUR
FACILITIES IN LEXINGTON KENTUCKY
THERE'S A SERIES OF TWELVE TESTS
TO VERIFY THE COMPOSITION OF THE
MATERIAL.
THOSE TESTS THROUGH THEN DONE%
FROM SEVEN LOCATIONS ON THE
TRACK IN ORDER TO VERIFY THE
CONSISTENCY -- SPATIALLY ON THE
TRACK THAT'S DONE BEFORE EVERY
RACE MEET IN THE CASE OF A LONG
RACE MEET LIKE SANTA NEEDED
STUNT SEASONALLY DURING -- IT'S
DONE BEFORE THE WINTER SEASON
STARTS AND BEFORE THE SUMMER
SEASON BECAUSE THERE'S TYPICALLY
SOME BIG CHANGES AT THAT POINT --
THEN PRIOR TO EACH RACE MEET WE
HAVE A CERTIFICATION PROCESS
THAT WE GO THROUGH THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH -- WHAT'S DONE
IN A LOT OF OTHER SPORTS SOCCER --
RUGBY AMERICAN FOOTBALL DOES NOT
TO IT OF WHERE WE USE A
BIOMECHANICAL SURFACE TESTER
THAT'S BECOME AN INTERNATIONAL
STANDARD THAT WAS ALSO DEVELOPED
USING -- HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I WAS IN MAINE AND
COLORADO WHILE WE WERE
DEVELOPING IT THERE WAS
CALIFORNIA THAT LED THAT EFFORT.
OF WE ALSO USE GROUND
PENETRATING RADAR TO VERIFY THE
SURFACE BEFORE EACH RACE MEET --
THAT'S IF YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH GROUND PENETRATING RADAR
THAT'S LIKE IF YOU WATCH THE
FORENSIC TV SHOWS WHERE YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR THE BODY THAT'S THE
SAME TECHNOLOGY WE USE THAT TO
VERIFY.
THE SUBSURFACE OF THE TRACK.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE THEN IS
THAT SHOWS THAT THE SURFACE OF
THAT SHOWS THAT THE SERVICE IS
APPLICABLES CANDIES CAN BE
SAFELY AND SAFE THING
CONSISTENTLY USE SO IN
PARTICULAR IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHEN THEY'RE
SWITCHING FROM SANTA NEEDED TO
DEL MAR -- THAT THE SURFACE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE HORSES HAVE A
SIMILAR SERVICE TO RACE ON AT
DEL MAR THE AS THEY DID ITS AND
THE NEED.
TO WE THEN HAVE A PROTOCOL THAT
USE DAILY FOR DOCUMENTATION OF
THE RACING SURFACE MAINTENANCE.
A WEATHER STATION THE LOGS THE
DATED EVERY FIFTEEN MINUTE
INTERVAL MOISTURE CONTENT
MEASUREMENTS TO MAKE AND ARE
TAKEN EVERY DAY -- PRIOR TO
RACING AND ALSO DOWNLOADED TO A
RELATIONAL DATABASE.
OUR GOAL IN THIS IS TO TREAT A
RACE TRACK LIKE YOU WOULD A AN
AIRPLANE WE EVERYBODY SAT ON THE
TARMAC WILL BE PREPARED THE RARE
AIRPLANE TO GET READY TO GO
WHERE THERE'S A CHECKLIST.
IT NEEDS TO BE CERTIFIED ALL THE
MAINTENANCE IS DONE.
AND THEN THE MAINTENANCE IS
CERTIFIED BY A SECOND PERSON WHO
DOES A CHECKLIST.
OUR INTENT IS.
TO CREATE A SAFETY CRITICAL
SERVICE.
WHICH THE RACING SERVICES IS
SAFETY CRITICAL.
PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY THAT USED
EVERY DAY WE'RE RISKING BOTH
RIDERS AND HORSES ON THOSE
SERVICES.
AND SO IT NEEDS THE SAME
STANDARDS OF CARE THAT WE THAT
WE WOULD PUT INTO A AIRPLANE
BEFORE WE BEFORE WE LET.
PASSENGERS FLYING ON IT
[inaudible]
SO -- I WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS WE'VE GOT TO IMPROVE
WE'RE AT WE'RE WHERE WE ARE --
AND WE HAVE WHAT WE HAVE AT THIS
POINT BUT THIS IS RACING
SERVICES NEED TO IMPROVE AND WE
NEED TO GO FORWARD THEM OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
TO FLY OUT HERE FROM KENTUCKY I
DID AND WITH A REALLY NICE SEVEN
SEVEN POWER POINT SLIDES THAT
WITH NICE PICTURES AND
EVERYTHING.
BUT IT'S ALL OVER ALL TAKE THE
CLIP LOCAL BACK TO MY OFFICE --
MAKE SURE YOU GET OF EVEN THE NO
I REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE I GUESS I I GUESS
BECAUSE IT'S FORGET.
DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON
WHAT'S HAPPENED HERE CALIFORNIA
YOU'RE AN EXPERT AT THE AT RACE
TRACKS -- YOU'VE SEEN A LOT OF I
MISSED IN YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENED OUT HERE
PARTICULARLY AT THE THE OTHER
ONE RACE TRACK AND SEE IF YOU'VE
GOT ANY COMMENTS -- YEAH
RELATIVE TO THAT WELL WHAT THE
WEATHER IS UNUSUAL THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT I MEAN WE TO
DO THE PEOPLE MENTIONED OTHER
THIRTEEN INCHES OF RAIN OUR ON
SITE WEATHER GAGE HAD SEVENTEEN
INCHES OF RAIN OVER THAT'S OVER
THAT -- OVER THAT TWO MONTH
PERIOD I MEAN YOU WE SEE THAT A
LOT ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
BUT THE CHALLENGES THIS IS ALSO
RACING SURFACE IT HAS TO BE USED --
DURING YOUR DRY HOT SUMMERS IN
ARCADIA SO THE CHALLENGES TO PUT
TOGETHER SURFACED THAT'S WILLING
TO THE TABLE TO HANDLE THAT
SEVENTEEN INCHES OF RAIN AND
ALSO HANDLE HANDLE THE DRY
PERIOD -- THAT SAID.
OKAY I I'LL AND SINCE I DON'T
HAVE MY SLIDE SO -- ALL USING
ENGINEERING ANALOGY FOR YOU HERE
AND I I I I I USE A SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN MAX -- BOEING AS AS THE
EXAMPLE AND I I THINK IT NEEDS
TO BE TAKEN THAT SERIOUSLY
[inaudible]
BUT YOU KNOW THERE IS A SERIES
OF THINGS THAT HAD TO GO WRONG
YOU KNOW YOU HAD TO HAVE.
THE DESIGN OF THE PLANE.
THE ANGLE OF ATTACK SENSORS THE
LACK OF GAUGES AND THE LACK OF
TRAINING.
AND WE HAVE TO APPROACH THIS THE
SAME WAY BOEING'S APPROACHING
THEIR PLAY.
WE CAN'T FIX ONE THING AND WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HANDLE
THAT WHETHER WE SHOULD HAVE HAD
WE SHOULD HAVE HAD PROCESSES IN
PLACE THAT COULD HANDLE THE
WEATHER AND WE DIDN'T AND THE
CHALLENGE AND THE NICE THING IS
IN THE THOROUGHBRED DAILY NEWS
BOB BAFFERT EVEN SAID.
THE SAME THING YOU GOT FROM THE
ENGINEERS SO I THINK THAT GIVES
IT SOME WHITE THE CHALLENGES
WHEN IT BEGINS TO DRY OUT.
AND IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS AND SAID I NEED
IS ONE OF MOST DIFFICULT TRACKS
TO MAINTAIN YOU CAN START OUT
THE RACE CARD WITH IT -- FLOATED
AND WET.
AND IF YOU HAVE A HOT DRY WIND
COMING OUT OF THE MOUNTAINS.
BY THE BY THE FIFTH OR SIXTH
RACE YOU MAY BE THINKING ABOUT
GETTING THE WATER TRUCKS OUT.
THAT'S AN INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT --
SITUATION FOR THE SUPERINTENDENT
TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS WE NEED TO
BRING TECHNOLOGY TO BEAR ON THIS
TO HELP SUPPORT THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S ON THOSE
DECISIONS MAKING THOSE DECISIONS
AND AND AND THIS IS WHERE?
OF OF WHAT -- BELINDA STRONACH
WAS TALKING ABOUT IS IS IS KEY
THIS IS THIS IS NOT A STATUS QUO.
INDUSTRY THIS NEEDS TO BE AN
INDUSTRY THAT LOOKS FORWARD TO
IT TWO NEW FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY DOUG -- BIRDS THIS ECONOMIC
IMPACT HORSE RACING.
RICK PICKERING AND JOHN
VALENZUELA -- DOUG IS PRESENT IN
THE CALIFORNIA THOROUGHBRED REAP
BREEDERS ASSOCIATION RECORDS A
BOARD MEMBER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
THREE RAISING FAIRS.
AND JOHN BALLOTS WILL IS PRESENT
IN THE PARA MUTUAL EMPLOYEES GO
TO CALIFORNIA.
I KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE COME ALL
THIS THIS WAY BUT WE GOT PUBLIC
COMMENT I NEED TO GET.
TO SO PLEASE LIKE SKIN NO.
I WILL BE QUICK AMONG YEAH I I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
BUT I I JUST NEEDED. TO GET THIS
PUBLIC COMMENT IN TODAY BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WHAT WE'RE
DOING THANK OKAY YEAH I'LL GO
FIRST I'LL BE.
I'LL BE REAL QUICK -- SO YOU
WAKE UP THANKS.
FOR PUTTING THIS ON DOUG BIRCH
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
THOROUGHBRED BREEDERS.
WE REPRESENT NOT ONLY THE
THOROUGHBRED BREEDERS IN THE
STATE -- BUT ALSO ALL THE HORSE
FARMS.
RACING SUPPORTS NEARLY EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND JOBS LARGE PERCENTAGES
OF THOSE JOBS ARE AT THE FARM
LEVEL.
YOUR THESE PEOPLE TAKE CARE OF
THE SOURCES FROM THE DAY THEY'RE
BORN. TO ALL THE EARLY
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING.
THEY GO TO OUR SALE THEY GO TO
THE RACETRACK.
BUT WHEN THEY COME BACK TO BE
BRED.
OR COME BACK TO LIVE THE REST OF
LIFE IN A IN A GRASS PADDOCK.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE -- ARE PART OF THIS
PROCESS.
CALIFORNIA'S THE THIRD LARGEST
FULL PRODUCING STATE IN THE
COUNTRY -- WE'RE JUST REALLY
NECK AND NECK WITH FLORIDA WITH
KENTUCKY OBVIOUSLY AT THE TOP.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
PRODUCING -- CHAMPION HORSES YOU
KNOW -- ONES THAT COME TO MIND
OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA CHROME TO
IS NOW -- AND MANY OTHERS WE
HAVE WON THE STRONGEST BREEDING
AND RACING PROGRAMS IN THE
COUNTRY -- THE RACETRACKS ARE
VERY DEPENDENT ON THESE
CALIFORNIA BRED HORSES WE MAKE
UP NEARLY HALF THE FIELD SIZES
NORTH AND SOUTH.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA MAKES UP
ABOUT 9% OF THE NATIONAL FULL
CROP.
BUT NOT PERCENT A FULL CROPS
MAKING UP.
LIKE I SAID ROUGHLY HALF OF OUR
FIELDS -- IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE.
AND THE CALIBRATED THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY A VERY IMPORTANT PART
OF IT -- JUST TO WRAP IT UP YOU
KNOW IS THE PRODUCERS OF THE
HORSE INVENTORY.
YOU KNOW WE WANT NOTHING MORE
THAN FOR RACING TO BE AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE -- WE SUPPORT ALL THE
MEASURES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED TODAY -- THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT INTO PLACE TO DO SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES HONORABLE CHAIRMAN SENATOR
DODD.
THANK YOU ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA'S
FORTY RACING FAIRS ALSO SEE YOUR
OF YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR.
CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR BEGAN
THOROUGHBRED RACING BACK IN.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR SO HORSE
RACING AHEAD EARLY START JUST
ABOUT AS EARLY AS STATE A
CALIFORNIA BEGAN.
ON THE NETWORK IN CALIFORNIA
FAIRS PARTICULARLY NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ACTUALLY ARE VERY PLEASED TO
REPORT TO THAT WE'VE HAD ZERO
FATALITIES ON OUR FIVE DIRT
RACETRACKS IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
WE ARE COGNIZANT THAT THINGS CAN
HAPPEN SERVICES ARE DIFFERENT
THERE'S CLIMATE CHANGES ETCETERA.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT THE STRONG AGE GROUP IN THE
HORSE RACING BOARD AS TO HELP US
ALL STAY SAFE -- BUT CAR FAIRS
REESING FAIRS CAME TOGETHER
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO AND
IMPLEMENTED A JOINT TO
STANDARDIZE APPROACH TO
MAINTAINING THOSE FIVE DIFFERENT.
RACING SURFACES IN FIVE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
WE'VE GONE TO DREADED TRACTORS
INSTEAD OF THE OLD LARGE RUBBER
TIRE TRACTORS.
WE DO A NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS
IN THAT WE SPEND ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
FOR EACH OF THOSE FIVE TRACKS
DOING SOIL TESTING AND SOIL
AMENDMENTS.
WE KNOW THE OTHER TRACKS DO
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR TO THAT --
WHEN IT COMES TO PUBLIC
PERCEPTION?
YOUR CALIFORNIA FAIRS COUNTY
FAIR STATE FAIRS ARE ON
LITERALLY THE CUTTING EDGE OF
ANIMAL HUSBANDRY CARE AND
WELFARE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE WORK HAND IN HAND WITH
NUMEROUS ANIMAL WELFARE
ORGANIZATIONS.
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
AND ARE HELD IN THE MEDIA TO
VERY HIGH STANDARD SO WHEN IT
COMES TO HORSE RACING -- THE
SAFETY OF YOUR CALIFORNIA FAIRS
WE BELIEVE WERE HELPING THE
IMAGE CAN OF THE FAIRS AND HORSE
RACING TO CONTINUE. TO BE
ENHANCED AND WHATEVER WE CAN DO
TO CONTRIBUTE ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS WE CERTAINLY WANT TO DO
THAT.
AND ARE COMMITTED TO HELPING
BOTH OF THESE COMMITTEES AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DODD
CHAIMAN GRAY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JOHN BOSWELL LONG AND
I AM PRESIDENT OF THE PARA
MEACHAM PLOYS GIL OF CALIFORNIA
LOCAL TO EIGHTY AFFILIATED WITH
THE S. C. I. YOU.
WE REPRESENT NEARLY ONE THOUSAND
PER MEACHAM PLOY EASE AT TRACKS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE THE WORKERS WHO MAKE SURE
EVERY CUSTOMER IS ABLE TO ENGAGE
IN THE MANY RACES CARRIED OUT AT
THE TRACK.
I HAVE BEEN A MEMBER OF LOCAL TO
EIGHTY AS A PERMIT TO CLERK AND
HAVE WORK FOR VARIOUS HORSE
RACING ASSOCIATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS.
MY FAMILY HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN
HORSE RACING FOR GENERATIONS IN
ALL ASPECTS.
AS OWNERS TRAINERS JOCKEYS
JOCKEY AGES GROOMED HOT WALKERS
AND PARA MUTUAL CLERKS.
MY FATHER WAS A HALL OF FAME
JOCKEY WHO REGULARLY ROAD KELSO
VOTED FIVE TIME HORSE OF THE
YEAR WINNER FROM. NINETEEN SIXTY
TO NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE HE WAS
ALSO A TWO TIME KENTUCKY DERBY
WINNER AND A TWO TIME.
PREAKNESS STAKES WINNER WITH TEN
TâM IN NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND
WITH FORWARD PASS IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT NOT ONLY IS
HORSE RACING IN MY BLOOD.
BUT THE WELL BEING OF HORSES IS
IN MY HEART.
QUITE SIMPLY WITHOUT THE HORSES
THERE IS NO HORSE RACING
INDUSTRY.
FROM MY UP CLOSE VIEW OF HORSE
RACING.
I KNOW HOW FAR THE INDUSTRY GOES
TO PLACE THE WELL BEING OF THE
HORSES FIRST.
LIKE THE MILLIONS OF HORSE
RACING FANS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE MEMBERS OF MY UNION OUR
HEART SICK OVER THE RECENT LOSS
OF ANIMALS WE LOVE AND ADMIRE.
WE SUPPORT CONTINUE EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE SAFETY AND WELL BEING
ACROSS INDUSTRY FOR THESE MUCH
BELOVED ANIMALS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD
MOST RECENT ANNUAL REPORT.
FOUND OUT FOUND THAT HORSE VISIT
FATALITIES IN CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING HAVE BEEN REDUCED NEARLY
60% OVER THE LAST THIRTEEN YEARS.
WITH MUCH OF THAT DECREASE IN
THE LAST YEAR ALONE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE RESULTS
OF THE INVESTIGATION TO THE DESK
AND SENDING IT TRACKS SO THAT WE
CAN ENSURE EVEN GREATER SAFETY.
FOR THE HORSES WE LOVE.
GETTING BACK TO RACING SAFETY IS
ALSO A MATTER OF SURVIVAL FOR
THOSE OF US WHO WORK WITH THE
HORSES.
AT ONE TIME HORSE RACING
CALIFORNIA HAPPEN FIVE OR SIX
DAYS A WEEK.
NOW WE ARE AT THREE OR FOUR
RACING AT SENDING THE TRACK IS
AT THREE OUR WORKERS HAVE BEEN
LOYAL TO THIS INDUSTRY FOR
DECADES AND EVERY WORKER
DESERVES THE STABILITY.
OF EMPLOYMENT ALONG WITH DIGNITY
AND RESPECT ON THE JOB.
THIS REDUCTION AFFECTS PARA
MUTUAL STAFF OTHER UNION MEMBERS
AT THE TRACKS AS WELL AS JOCKEYS
OWNERS TRAINERS INVENTORS. FOR
EXAMPLE ONE OF OUR LOCAL TO
EIGHTY MEMBERS TERRY BENTSEN HAS
BEEN DEEPLY IMPACTED BY THE
REDUCTION TO THREE DAYS A WEEK.
SHE WAS FORCED TO GET ANOTHER
JOB TO SUPPORT THE SUPPLEMENTARY
INCOME AND IS USING A CAR GIVEN
TO HER BY HER FAMILY FOR
TRANSPORTATION.
SHE'S BARELY MAKING ENDS MEET.
AND AS HER INCOME IS BELOW
POVERTY LEVEL SHE HAS MOVED INTO
SECTION EIGHT HOUSING.
SHE WANTS TO WORK FULL TIME AND
MAKE A DECENT LIVING WAGE AND
REGAIN SOME OF HER DIGNITY AND
RESPECT AFTER THIRTY YEARS OF
EMPLOYMENT IN THE RACING
INDUSTRY.
SHE WORRIES THAT THE INSTABILITY
WILL MEAN CONTINUED STRUGGLE OUT
OR I'M SORRY TO DO THIS CHEN
INJURE WRAP UP OKAY.
YEAH I'M ALMOST DONE HERE SO --
MEETS CONSIST DRIVE FOR HER
FAMILY HER WORRIES ARE SHARED BY
MANY OTHER TRACK EMPLOYEES WHEN
SENDING IT WAS CLOSED IN MARCH
OUR MEMBERS WERE OUT OF WORK
WITH NO INCOME.
THE CURRENT ACTION IN RACINE
DAYS REPRESENTS 25% CUT IN
MEMBERS WEEKLY INCOME.
MONEY THEY NEED TO PAY THEIR
MORTGAGE RAN AND EVEN THEIR KIDS
COLLEGE TUITION.
STAFFING REDUCTIONS ACROSS THE
STATE MEANS SOME MEMBERS HAVE
LOST THEIR JOBS COMPLETELY.
UNION MEMBERS WHO WERE ABLE TO
WORK EVERY WEEK AND NOW FIND
THEMSELVES WITH NO WORK AT ALL
[inaudible]
IN CONCLUSION.
A CONCLUSION OF I'VE I MADE ONLY
I JUST READ YOUR WHOLE SPEAK GO
IT GO AHEAD IN CONCLUSION WE
SUPPORT SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE
CONDITIONS THE RACING INDUSTRY.
AND THE WELL BEING OF ALL HORSES
BUT WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COST AND LOSS OF WORK TO ALL
PEOPLE IN THE INDUSTRY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME I THINK WE ALL DO
TO THANK YOU THANK ALL OF YOU
VERY VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA GO THERE WAS A
SCRATCH AT THE GATE.
WE CANCELED THE THOROUGHBRED
AFTER CARE IN AWARENESS RACE.
WILL NOT BE HAPPENING TODAY
WE'LL JUST HAVE TO GET BACK TO
THAT A DIFFERENT TIME WE'RE
MOVING TO GET NOBODY'S EVEN
LAUGHTER THAT'S OUT LATER.
ALL RIGHT SO.
YEAH SO ANYWAY WE'RE GONNA GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW DO WE HAVE A
MIKE READY.
HOW MANY HOW MANY WISHING -- TO
AS A PUBLIC COMMENT JUST COME UP
TO THE TABLE.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR WAITING I KNOW THE
YOU HAD.
I'M GOING.
TO APPLY.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD HERE DONE.
AND EVERYONE -- I'M JUDY MAN
CREW SO FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF
SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION AS MOST OF YOU KNOW
WE ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF THE
VOICELESS IN CALIFORNIA.
ANIMAL LOVERS SUCH AS MYSELF AND
OUR SUPPORTERS WANT TO KNOW SO
THAT ALL THE WANT TO KNOW THAT
ALL THE FORCES THAT HAVE DIED
HAVE NOT DIED IN VAIN WE NEED TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE OF HORSE RACE
SCENE AND THE TIME IS NOW NO
MORE DELAYS AND NO MORE.
EXCUSES PERSONALLY I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE THE TRACK OWNERS FIND
ANOTHER WAY TO MAKE MONEY AND
MAINTAIN OR GROW JOBS SUCH AS
TURNING THEIR VENUES INTO OTHER
MONEY MAKING FACILITIES OR INTO
HOUSING THAT IS SORELY NEEDED IN
OUR STATE.
OR ANY OTHER OF THE MANY
OPPORTUNITIES THAT EXIST FOR
THEM EACH OF THESE NEW POTENTIAL
TRANSFORMATIONS CAN CREATE JOBS
EVEN THE POTENTIAL FOR MANY MORE
JOBS WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE
ANIMALS USED IN ENTERTAINMENT GO
BY THE WAYSIDE.
THESE ANIMALS COULD NOT SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES ON WHEN THEY ARE
IN PAIN OR NOT UP TO RUNNING
AROUND THE TRACK AN UNNATURAL
SPEEDS.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE TREATED AS A
DISPOSABLE COMMODITY TO BE
ABUSED FORSAKEN AND THROWN AWAY.
HOWEVER IF THE TIME IS NOT RIGHT
THEN WE MUST RAISE OUR STANDARDS
TO BE THE HIGHEST IN THE WORLD
AND NOT ONE MORE HORROR SHOULD
DIE.
THERE ARE PREVENTIVE MEASURES
THAT CAN BE TAKEN TO ENSURE THIS
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT BE BEHIND
HONG KONG AND DO BY WE NEED NOT
ONLY TO MATCH THEIR STANDARDS
BUT TO EXCEED THEM.
MY GROUP IS WORKING ALONGSIDE
PIZZA AS SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
KATHY GILL AMERO WHO IS THE
LEADING EXPERT IN HORSE RACING
FOR THE ANIMAL RIGHTS COMMUNITY
WE ARE ALSO WORKING WITH THE
STRONG A GROUP BELINDA AND HER
TEAM WHO ARE OPEN AND WILLING
PARTNERS FOR CHANGE AS YOU HEARD
HERE.
TODAY AND THE C. H. R. B. WHO
HAS NOT HAD AS MANY WILLING
PARTICIPANTS IN THE PAST TO SEE
THROUGH GROUNDBREAKING STANDARDS
FOR THEIR INDUSTRY WE HAVE MET
MULTIPLE TIMES WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S STAFF AND MANY OTHERS
IN THE LEGISLATURE.
LEGISLATURE TO BEGIN CREATING
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THE MAJOR
CHANGE CHANGES THAT MUST BE
AMPLE MINUTE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND IN THE UPCOMING
MONTHS WE WILL BE MOVING
LEGISLATION.
AND OF COURSE FOR THE MAJESTIC
COURSES THAT NEEDLESSLY DIED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M GOING TO
THE AIRPORT.
BUT BY NEXT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MY NAME'S CATHY GILLIAM -- I'M
WITH PEOPLE FOR THE ETHICAL
TREATMENT OF ANIMALS OR PIZZA
I'M ALSO A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT --
EVERYBODY TODAY HAS HAD A LOT OF
INTERESTING COMMENTS ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE HORSES WHO DIED BUT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THAT EVERY YEAR DOZENS AND
DOZENS OF HORSES DIE ON
CALIFORNIA RACETRACKS.
AND WE KNOW FROM NEW CROPS IS
DONE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS THE PRE
EXISTING INJURIES AT THE SIGHT
OF THOSE BREAKS OFTEN EXIST.
WHY DOES THIS HAPPEN MEDICATIONS
THAT MASK INJURIES ARE GIVEN
LEGALLY AND THIS CAUSES A
PROBLEM I DON'T THINK IT'S JUST
A WEIRD ANOMALY THAT IN SIX
WEEKS THERE WERE NO DEATHS AT
SANTA ANITA?
I THINK THE RULES THAT SANTA
NEED TO PUT IN PLACE ARE WORKING
AND THOSE RULES INVOLVE PULLING
BACK ON THOSE MEDICATIONS AND
NOT MAKING SURE THE INJURED
HORSES ARE GOING ON THE TRACK.
WE NEED TO DO MORE OF THAT
THERE'S MORE THAT CAN BE DONE
MORE MEDICATION WITHDRAWAL
HORSES SHOULDN'T BE RUNNING ON
FETAL BUTTE IS OWN IS
ESSENTIALLY ALL OF THEM ARE IN
TWO DAYS BEFORE.
A RACE THERE IS SOPHISTICATED
SCAN TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL SCAN
ON ALL FOUR LEGS OF A HORSE
SIMULTANEOUSLY IN UNDER ONE
MINUTE AND DETECT A LOT OF THIS
INJURY.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT I THINK THAT
VIOLATORS BE KICKED OUT OF THE
SPORT THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WITH DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
MEDICATION VIOLATIONS AND THEY
NEED TO GO.
THERE'S MORE THAT CAN BE DONE
BUT MOST OF ALL FORCES SHOULD
NOT BE THE COLLATERAL DAMAGE IN
RACING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THAT
INCLUDES -- THIS HEARING I DO
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR ITS
HERE STILL -- THE HANG HANG OUT
THE ENTIRE TIME WE APOLOGIZE FOR
THIS IS A TOUGH TIME A YEAR TO
HAVE.
A HEARING BECAUSE BOTH HOUSES
ARE INVOLVED IN -- THE HOUSE OF
LORDS SHOULD DEADLINES HEARING
ALL THE BILLS BUT WE FELT THAT
THIS WAS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE -- IN OUR STATE WE WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE YEAH WE AT
LEAST HAD THE HEARING.
THAT HAD STARTED AN HOUR LATER I
FEEL REALLY GOOD WE CAN BE GIVEN
EVERYBODY THAT.
THE TIME AND RESPECT THEY NEEDED
I APOLOGIZE TO ANYBODY IF I WAS
OFFENSIVE TRIED.
TO GET HERE BY SIX PM BUT THIS
MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
YEAH